- The most ghetto thing that I have
is that I'm actually using a
bed sheet as a mattress cover.
- Wait, what?
(jaunty music)
How do you stretch that sheet over it?
- With a lot like the
fucking power of Zeus.
I'm like...
(Joey laughs)
(groans)
I'm, like pulling the
red sea back together.
It's a zip, it goes
all around my mattress.
- Oh, you fucking zipped
it around your mattress.
(soft music)
- What's up, G Fuel enthusiasts.
Welcome back to another episode
of the "Trash Taste Podcast." (laughs)
- That's what you came up with.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- That is it?
- That is it.
- Okay.
- He literally just looked
at the nearest thing
next to him (indistinct).
- Yeah, I was like
uh, G Fuel.
- Oh my God.
- He's just playing I Spy at this point.
(laughs)
- All right, welcome back.
I'm with the boys as usual,
Connor and Garnt.
- Yes.
- Did you see-
- I am Steve Hanjobs though.
- Yeah, Steve Hanjobs,
you are, yes.
- Bringing back
the Steve Hanjobs cosplay.
(claps)
- I am so glad that you're
making that a character.
- What is this podcast.
(laughs)
- I am so glad, I was like-
- Every time I wear a turtleneck now-
- Yeah, you're Steve Hanjobs.
- Yeah.
- Why do you have
so many turtlenecks, Garnt?
- 'Cause it's fucking cold in Japan, okay?
- I never saw you wearing
turtle necks until this year.
And suddenly this man's
got a fucking-
- No, no, no, no, no.
He's always worn turtlenecks.
- No he hasn't.
- Yes he has.
- Fuck off.
- Basically before, because
I lived in Thailand,
so all the only winter clothes
I had were turtlenecks.
And I would just, every time
I come to Japan in the winter-
- First time I met Garnt, he
was wearing a black turtleneck.
- It's like, Garnt during
summer, Neanderthal.
Garnt during winter,
big brain five head.
(laughs)
I'm wearing the turtleneck mother.
- Not gonna lie, I've never
looked good in a turtleneck,
so I've personally never worn it.
And I think Garnt is
the only person I know
that actually rocks turtleneck.
- You have to be kinda skinny though
to pull off a turtle neck.
- Yes, you need to be skinny,
and you also need to have a neck.
(laughing)
Like a long neck.
- Sorry, Ed.
- Big Ed's swearing right now.
(laughing)
I just imagined big Ed in a turtle neck.
It covers his entire face.
- He'll just look like roll on deodorant.
(laughing)
- I'm sorry Ed.
I'm sorry we're take
cheap shots at you, man.
You're questionable Ed, but. (chuckles)
- Remember that was the thing
in 2020, the big Ed thing.
- Big Ed.
- So many good memes.
- That was so good.
- Can we just all agree that back in 2020,
which is still when we're
filming this by the way,
that My Little Pogchamp
was the worst meme of 2020.
Can we just agree?
I don't know what meme of the year was,
but that was the worst.
- But it was definitely
not that fucking meme.
I should say that.
- I don't know, that meme kind of...
One, it came out of nowhere
and two, it died so fast.
- Well because it was shit,
it was shit.
- I know.
- And I'm so glad that it was animated,
so that the poor person who
voiced it didn't get fucking
obliterated.
(laughs)
- [Joey] Destroyed, yeah.
- Can you imagine if that
was like a person on TikTok,
it'd be like, oh my God,
it's the Pogchamp girl.
- Oh God.
I guarantee there's a number of girls
who went on to TikTok
and did the whole voice-
- Yeah, yeah there is.
Of course there is.
- I'm not gonna look.
- Have you had TikTok's of
people voicing over your videos?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So, she went and did
a lot of anime character stuff.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There's loads and they
fully dress up in costume.
- I've heard people doing that
of just me talking like normally.
Like they would take a
segment of me from like an-
- So, you just get a fandub?
- Yeah.
- That's just a fandub,
extra steps.
- I saw a bunch where someone
took really old audio of me
in like an answer me simp
or where I'm just fucking
answering a question normally.
And they just like voicing
over and acting over.
I was like, I mean there's-
- [Connor] Content.
- There's lots of audio
clips you could have taken
that's a little more interesting, right?
- Do you ever get people
impersonating your voice?
I get that a lot.
- Yeah, but that's 'cause
you have a distinct voice.
- I guess.
- I don't exactly have a distinct voice.
- There's a few videos out
there of people like...
I think I mentioned this
before on the podcast, right?
Where they like go around on
discord, pretending to be me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And film the reaction.
- I don't have crazy fans like you,
so no.
- Oh fuck.
(Joey laughs)
- And what, do they just do the most
broken English accent?
- They're like,
"Hello, I'm Connor."
- Hello, hello.
- And then everyone's like,
"Oh my God, its Cdawgva."
(Joey laughs)
And I'm like what?
I'm like that is not me.
It doesn't sound like me.
Why are you believing this man?
- Hello, I'm Connor.
- Hello, governor.
- Literally a terrible British accent.
(laughs)
It doesn't sound remote-
- But with a deep voice.
- Oh yeah, just doesn't
even sound remotely like me.
It's just British accent,
deep voice.
- Oy, oy, oy, oy, oy,
what's going on here.
(Joey laughs)
- They'll be like-
- This is a Cdawgva video,
this is.
Hello there.
- Oh my God,
its the real Cdawgva.
- [Meilyne] Imagine how Micheal feels.
- Oh, yeah, poor Michael.
They'll like do...
Yeah, exactly.
People will impersonate Sebastian,
but not like the actual Sebastian.
They'll impersonate like my Sebastian.
- The Cdawgva Sebastian.
- Yeah, Sebastian.
- But they'll be like
in an American accent.
Oh how the fuck do I do this,
'cause I'm so ingrained
to do this in British.
It'd be like, 'cause you
know Sebastian's catchphrase.
- Yeah.
- I'm simply one hell
of a butler, right?
There'll be like, "I'm
simply one hell of a butler."
(laughing)
And it'll be like...
And it was awful. 'cause it
would sound like half English,
half American attempt,
and it's like, what?
And then-
- That was like layered-
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- That was layered there.
- That was hard to do.
I was like how do I break barrier.
- That took like 100% of
your brain power to do.
- A British person impersonating
an American person,
impersonating a British person.
(laughs)
- Then I'd be like, I would
hear these voices they would do
and I'm like, there's no way
they're gonna believe that.
And then the moment they do
it, they're like, "It's Cdawg.
"Oh, my God."
(Joey laughs)
And I'm like what?
This isn't me.
And then there was someone as well
who went on voice acting
websites trying to be me
called It's Connor or something.
- It's Connor.
- And they would go around
making references to my videos.
Like I fucking reference myself.
(Joey laughs)
Like I go around being like,
oh yes, remember that time
I was Sebastian, good times.
Who the fuck references themselves?
That's something like Tommy
Wiseau shit. (chuckles)
You know what I mean?
Who actually does?
- Like it's the only thing you have.
- Yeah, it's like I've made it now.
I'm done making new stuff.
I'm just gonna reference
myself until I'm entire...
(indistinct) what?
Then people are like, "Shit, it's Cdawg."
- Yeah.
He said the thing, so it must be him.
- It infuriates me to
death, 'cause I'm like,
if this is all it takes to
get you to believe this is me
I hope your credit card gets stolen.
You deserve it.
(laughs)
Like you had a it coming
if you think that's me.
I'm kidding. (laughs)
- Yeah, true.
No, no seriously.
I haven't had people
impersonating my voice,
but I've had people
kind of trying to do it
by just speaking in a
shitty Australian accent.
- Yeah.
- And sometimes the voice
is totally not me.
It's a completely different voice.
But because they're
speaking in a semi like-
- [Connor] Right, right.
- Oh, I'm fucking Australian, aye.
- It is pretty funny how much room
people are willing to
give-for interpretation.
- [Joey] It's so crazy.
- I've not seen any TikTok's,
but I've had exactly the same comments
of like some random YouTuber
who is reviewing anime clips or something
in a slight British accent.
- Gigguk.
- And they're like,
"Oh my God, it's Gigguk.
It's fucking Gigguk.
(laughing)
The thing that annoys me more actually,
is not on YouTube or
TikTok, but it's on Twitter,
where apparently anyone Southeast Asian
who posts a selfie now
who's also into anime,
it's just like, "Oh my
God, you look like Gigguk."
You do?
- Oh my God, I have so many
photos fucking of people,
just like random Indian celebrities.
(Garnt laughing)
And people are just like,
"Yo, I thought that was Joey."
What the fuck?
(laughing)
Like I had a guy, my
sister even sent me one.
It was like, she found on TV
there was this Bollywood movie
or I guess some Bollywood show.
- Right, right, right, right.
- That they were promoting
on an ad or something.
And apparently one of the
dudes just straight up
apparently looked like me.
And I'm like, he's just
a Brown man with a beard.
That doesn't make (indistinct)
- That's you.
- Apparently every Brown
man with a beard is me.
- Yeah, I get that with white dudes.
Every white dude with a beard on TikTok,
is like, for some reason...
(Joey laughs)
They say I looked like Cedar.
I'm like, what the fuck, no.
Come on.
- Is there like any moment
where that kind of like,
oh, that you look like so-and-so person
has been kind of flattering?
I've only had one example of that,
and that's when people said
that I looked like, what was it?
A cracked out Jason Momoa.
(laughing)
It's like, oh, you look like Jason Momoa,
if he didn't work out.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- And I was like, yeah, I'll take that.
Jason Momoa's a fucking good looking dude.
- I think I had like
Benedict Cumberbatch once,
but I was like-
- You had Benedict Cumberbatch
- Right, right.
But I used to have really big curly hair
that looked similar to him,
so my parents just joked
that I was like him.
And cool, 'cause I was also like-
- British.
- Yeah, British.
My parents are British too, Joey,
what do you mean?
- Yeah, I know.
- Oh he's British fucking aye. (laughs)
- He's a British man, therefore,
he looks like Benedict Cumberbatch.
- Oh, fuck it, I was like, no, I don't.
I don't look like that fucking armature.
(laughing)
No, he's nice, he's fun.
We like him.
We have fun.
- Do you have one Garnt?
- I don't know.
- Garnt's too distinct.
- Yeah.
- Garnt has a very distinct-
- 'Cause nobody really knows
anything about Southeast Asia.
So, now it's just like
we are like the new,
just like Japanese or Chinese people
right now.
(Joey laughs)
'Cause now there're like
Chinese and Japanese culture
is been more like, and
Koreans have been more-
- Pushed out, right?
- Globalized.
- Yeah.
- Like all Southeast
Asians we'll just sit here
in our own corner being like,
well, there's more than one
country here as well, guys.
- It's gone from, I
can't tell the difference
between Japanese,
Koreans, and Chinese too.
- Yeah.
- I can't tell the difference
between Thai, Filipinos.
- Malaysians.
- Vietnamese.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- Fuck, I'd feel called out.
(laughing)
- But no, it's not like half
the memes on our subreddit,
it's just like a different
white person with a beard
and it's just like, oh my God it's-
- He is Connor.
- Its Connor, I thought it was Connor.
- It's a monkey brain.
- I got no beard now, actually.
Well, I just shaved it like two days ago.
- The amount of memes
though of you with baby face
is hilarious.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
- I do look
like a 10-year-old without a beard.
- Someone fucking posted
it on the subreddit
this old ass photo of me in a suit.
Have you guys seen that one?
- Yeah I saw that, that was funny.
- Yeah, I was like, why?
- How did they find that, it's on Google?
- It's on my Instagram, I think.
- Oh, okay. (chuckles)
- Yeah, it's like the second ever photo
I put up on Instagram.
(laughing)
It was six years old or something.
- You do look so shad as a baby.
- I know.
I was like, fuck, how old was I?
Like 20, maybe.
- You just looked like the
kind of kid who was like,
get me out of here.
- Yeah, I did, yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
I regret putting that photo up-
(laughing)
It's not a good photo of me.
- For me, I feel like
I haven't changed much
my look apart from...
The only thing that's
changed is the spikiness
of my hair over the years.
(Joey laughs)
- You've calm down, you've calm down.
- You can tell the Gigguk
years by the younger I am,
like the more spikes in the hair.
- Yeah.
- Like there are.
You look at some of my first videos
and I look like fucking Sasuke, man.
- I'm wondering,
(Joey laughs)
how did you decide on that hair style?
'cause that's a look, right?
- Is that hair you've had
since we were young or?
- No, I think, I can't remember.
I just remember...
Because I have hair that's really easy
to be spiked up, right?
- Right.
- So, I think ever since
I was young-
- What constitutes a hair
that's easy to just spike up?
- Like light and-
- Oh, okay.
- Could you spike up your hair?
- Yeah, easily.
- No, because of my
hair, if I cut it short,
I put a bit of water in it
and it just immediately, naturally,
it's just like the fucking
anime character spike-
- A lot of Asian hair has that too.
'Cause my hair is also quite strawry.
So if I put gel in it
and it's just up forever
- Oh, I don't know.
- Yeah, no, I get that.
(chuckles)
Then again, it's like,
just because your hair can do that,
(Garnt laughs)
doesn't mean you have
to commit to it, right?
- Okay, was it inspired by anime?
- No. No,
it wasn't inspired by anime.
- Fuck off.
What was it inspired by?
- It was inspired by the...
There's only-
- Sonic the Hedgehog? (laughs)
- There's only so many
hairstyles I could pull off
and I had no idea what the
fuck I was doing with my hair.
Therefore, look, it was the hairstyle
that took the least
amount of effort to do,
because all I would-
- No, no, no, no.
- That look like a lot of effort.
- It was not.
Okay, it wasn't, because, like I said,
my hairstyle is just naturally spiky.
So, all I would need to do,
just put a bit of water,
put a bit of gel and just go.
- And they were like peaks bro.
It was done.
- You had like
fucking mountains.
- It naturally went to that shape.
- Naturally Sonic the Hedgehog.
- Yeah, Naturally Sonic the Hedgehog.
- I just woke up and I was Sonic.
(laughing)
What can I say?
No, because I remember
in some older videos,
your hair is like so...
It looked like a wig.
- Yeah, yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- That's how perfect the spike was.
I was like, this man could pass off
as like a side character "Yuyo."
- It was like you'd been watching
too many David Bowie concerts.
(laughs)
And you were like,
all right, I like that.
I'ma mimic that, basically.
That's what it looked like.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I wasn't trying to mimic anything.
I just had no idea what the fuck
I was doing with my hair.
- It was like some guy
who was trying to bring back
the '80s glam rock scene.
- Because, it's like
whatever the Mr. Anime
you talking about
that video pop ups-
- Oh, my God.
- It's so funny watching
that and seeing Garnt,
with this teenage hair.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which is really, really sad.
(laughing)
- I feel bad but 'cause
obviously you're my mate
I'm like that's funny.
- If you didn't know the context
and you just saw the thumbnail,
it looks like those angsty fucking video.
(chuckles)
- It is.
It totally fucking is.
- I can't focus 'cause you're fucking hair
is like Sonic the Hedgehog
where you're talking about-
- It's like 60% of the frame.
- You're talking about,
like argue the most serious thing ever
and you've got like
this fucking Sonic hair,
and (laughing) I can't focus on it.
- 'Cause I'm just talking about,
yeah, this guy just like
killed his family.
- Killed his family.
- But bro, that fucking hair though,
that fucking Sonic hair.
- Meanwhile this man's hair
has it's own orbit.
(laughing)
Oh, my God.
- Well yes, welcome to
"Trash Taste" where we are-
- Trash on each other's haircuts.
- Now we're trashing on
each other's haircuts.
- As good mates do.
- That's what we do.
- That's what constitutes
as a mirror.
Can you really call your mate a mate
if they don't make fun
of you after a haircut?
- Okay, what age did you reach,
where you actually paid attention
and gave a shit about
what you looked like?
'Cause I was really fucking late.
- Yeah, same.
- 'Cause literally the reason
I looked like that was because
I didn't really give a shit,
about what I looked like.
- Right.
- Until I got to my first,
second year of uni.
- Yeah, I was probably about the same.
- Did you ever have any interest in dating
when you where in-
- No.
- You didn't never wanna
date a girl in school?
- Oh, I was on an all boys school.
- I mean, of course I did.
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- I love my boys, but not like that.
- It's like, yeah, I
invite them to Kiss X Sis
but we don't kiss.
- Yeah.
- We don't kiss.
We'll have a session Kiss X Sis
but I don't care what you
look like, it's all right.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah, I guess maybe it's because
I went to a boys school that,
not to say that I didn't
hang out with girls.
- Man I fucking
would have loved to have
gone to a boys school, yeah.
Even get the pressure of having a fucking,
trying to get a girlfriend.
- Impress.
Yeah, yeah.
- And trying to get
a girlfriend 'cause everyone
else is getting one.
- Yeah, I mean, not to say that I didn't
have any interest in dating
but it's just like, it
wasn't a priority for me.
- Bro, I was speed running
them in school, man.
I never had one that
lasted more than two weeks.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- That was school relationships.
- I had one that lasted three months
and the boys were like, "Damn,
you lasted three months?"
- No, if you last more than-
- Three months is a long time
in high school.
- In high school,
it's a long time.
- That's a dedicated relationship.
- Yeah.
- Anything beyond a month
is like, okay, I am dedicated to this.
They're probably getting
married, you know what I mean?
- Exactly (chuckles),
it's like one step away
from marriage, right?
We've passed three months, damn.
My life's set already after this.
- I think I must have
started paying attention
to how I looked at maybe...
Okay, I say how I looked,
the hair, basically.
Everything else was like,
what am I gonna wear,
fucking school outfit?
- Oh yeah.
- My mum still bought
all my clothes, so like I was-
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Not gonna lie, I didn't
start buying my own clothes
until I moved out here.
- So, same.
- Same here, same here.
- My mom was just like, yeah,
I got this nice T-shirt.
It was like some shitty
$5 T-shirt from Target,
and I was like, yeah fuck, I'll wear that.
- My mom still buys me
clothes and sends them.
- Really?
- And it sucks that she has
fucking better taste than me.
- You know what's weird,
Aki's mom buys me clothes.
(laughs)
But my own mother doesn't anymore.
- I remember us, we
did a shoot a week ago,
and I remember Joey had to
borrow one of your T-shirts.
And just see Joey in one of your T-shirts,
I'm just like, this is
such a Connor shirt.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it was just like
a plain T-shirt-
- It's literally that,
but a different color.
- It's a plain T-shirt
in a drab color.
- Okay.
- And I'm just like,
(laughs)
man, this just screams Connor, right now.
- It's a color that I would never buy,
and it's a color that
Connor would definitely buy.
- Okay, this is gonna be one of those
weird Connor things, right?
- Right?
- Only like last year have
I been open to the idea
with owning shirts that have
nothing but plain color.
- [Joey] Right.
- For some reason, in my head-
- Is it because you don't like logos or?
- I hated logos and prints,
they drove me insane.
- Why?
- Really?
- I don't know, for some reason
it just looked cheap to me and always...
I mean that it's kinda-
- Oh no, I get that.
- It's kinda like
it costs me that 'cause
normally they're cheaper
these colors.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I get that though.
- It depends,
because some of them can look very tacky.
And I feel like there's a fine line
between having a cool print
and having a cool piece of artwork
that just looks tacky on a T-shirt.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's the whole concept
of simple is best, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Sometimes...
That's like the whole
reason why all of those
high brand shirts and shit like
that are so fucking simple.
- I think that's what changed my opinion
of fashion in general.
I have started to be more open to spending
a bit more money on clothes.
- Right.
- 'Cause at the end of the day
it's like, all right,
I'm wearing this shirt
for like how many months?
And I'm gonna be on camera
as well, especially.
So, I wanna wear shirts,
I know today I'll see.
(laughing)
But, I've still got a little
bit of the old me left.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Obviously, recently,
I've been like okay, I'm
willing to spend like...
Oh, I might spend 80 bucks on T-shirt,
which is unthinkable to
me through the years.
- Oh, yeah. Absolutely.
- Because, bear in mind
in university, I used to go to Primark,
which if you don't know
where Primark is in the UK-
- Yeah, I've been to Primark.
- Yeah so-
- Primark's amazing
by the way.
- It's basically-
- If you bought shirt
on Primark, I'm gonna fight you on that.
- Well, I don't wanna question
how they make their shirts so damn cheap.
I'm sure there's some ethical question.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
I remember, I specifically
bought eight T-shirts
for 10 pounds,
(Joey laughs)
which is like $15.
- It's amazing.
- And I fucking love these shirts,
'cause they were all plain.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Nothing on them.
And I wore them for like two
years straight, these shirts.
- Oh yeah, I-
- They were fucked by
the end of it, right?
- For real though, Primark
is like one of the best
low budget clothing brands
I've ever seen globally.
- Yeah, true, true.
- Honestly the shit
you can get for the price at Primark,
which I don't know where
Primark's available
internationally, 'cause i know-
- Its in Europe, I think.
- Is it in Europe?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's like, if
you wanna budget place
where you can just buy cheap clothes
that don't really don't look cheap.
You know what I mean?
- 'Cause people said,
Uniqlo here is cheap.
And we have Uniqlo in the UK.
- It's not cheap.
- Uniqlo compared to
Primark is very cheap.
- Uniqlo is cheap for
the quality that you get.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- You'll pay a little bit
extra for a T-shirt at Uniqlo,
but that shit is gonna last
you like 10 plus years.
- I bought a whole suit
from Primark for like $40,
(laughs)
that I wore to-
- 30 pounds?
The 30 pound set, yeah?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I did exactly the same
for my prom and everything.
- My graduation I wore
a $40 suit and actually,
I hate to say it, but it
doesn't look that bad.
It's not bad.
- It's not bad, that's the thing.
Primark basically, carried
my university years.
You know what I mean?
- But, there's a big but.
And a lot of people in the UK
tend to also have the
same mindset, I think,
where a T-shirt should never
cost more than 20, 30 pounds-
- Yeah, Yeah, yeah.
- Which I can understand,
because if you haven't got a lot of money,
spending that much on one
T-shirt is it's quite a lot,
it's quite a lot.
- Yeah.
- But, as I started to...
I think that's where my
hatred of prints started.
Is that I thought a lot
of these Primark ones
are pretty fucking shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And they often
do look super tacky.
And I don't really like
the collaborations.
They have like SpongeBob and shit.
And then they like, oh, we
stuck a PlayStation logo on it.
- I think they're just
starting to do anime, as well.
- Yeah, they are.
- Which is weird.
I feel like, was it
last year where they did
like a DBZ a one piece
collaboration, as well?
- Yeah, there's been a
lot of stores like that
Like Forever 21, as well,
before they went under,
they did this huge
fucking thing with anime.
So every time I went to Forever 21,
there was always this
entire section of anime.
But when you look at it, when
you actually go over to it,
you're just like, all right,
let's see what they have.
It's all like Sailor Moon,
Dragon Ball Z, Naruto.
- It's always the fucking basics.
- It's all the basic shit.
- And I'm like,
don't give me that.
I don't want-
- And it's not even done
in a creative way either.
It's just like, let's just slap the logo
and the main character, boom!
- Doing anime clothes is really hard.
And I'm probably gonna about to call out
a bunch of our viewers by saying this,
but the ones I hate the most are the ones
where it's just a T-shirt
with a waifu on it.
- Oh, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Or the anime logo.
- Or like a anime logo.
Those kinds of clothes I call
anime convention clothes.
'Cause it's a T-shirt or
clothes that I would only wear
to an anime convention,
but there's no way I would wear it
(indistinct)-
- You know what I call
clothes like that?
- What?
- Pajamas.
(laughing)
This is the only time
I'm fucking wearing it.
Is when I need to wear something in bed.
(Joey laughs)
- But there's probably someone
watching this right now
in like a fucking Asuna T-shirt,
they'd be like, aw.
- But I like this.
- Yeah.
And then I think as well,
going back to the whole
cheap versus expensive stuff
for clothes, like it's only...
I think 'cause I moved to
Japan, I actually started seeing
some of the clothes that I really like
and it's kind of expensive.
But you're like, okay, I
am gonna wear this a lot.
Like when I paid 350 bucks,
fuck, for that Diavolo...
Sorry, King Crimson jacket.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- When I bought that,
that was the most expensive
thing I'd ever bought,
clothes wise.
And I thought, oh my
God, this is insane, but-
- This peak. (laughs)
- This is insane, $350
on a fucking jacket.
Okay, it's sexy, look on screen it's sexy.
- But now that I've been wearing it,
I wear it pretty much every day.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, okay,
if I'm wearing it every day
and I get maybe four or
five years out of that,
that's like 20-
- You're getting bang
for your buck, right?
- You know what I mean.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And I understand that,
'cause I always felt that
way with tech, right?
Like to me it's like,
don't buy a $20 headset,
buy a $100, at least,
'cause you're gonna
get your money's worth.
And I don't know why for
some reason took me so long
to have that with fashion.
And I think going back to the
whole topic, which is school
and why I didn't give a fuck,
is 'cause I just didn't care for clothes.
I didn't really understand fashion at all.
- I just look like-
- I mean, who does?
- I mean high school.
- There was always that
one kid in your school,
who somehow always fucking
dressed amazing to shit.
Did you all have that kid?
- I didn't have that kid.
- I did not have that kid.
I always, I don't know,
I had kind of a similar view of fashion,
which is just I didn't get it.
- No I didn't get it.
- I didn't understand anyone
who would spend above like, yeah $20
or like $30 on a T-shirt.
- Yeah, I think my mum would scoff
if an outfit was over a total $50.
She'd be like,
(Joey laughs)
"Get a load of this scam."
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- I think that's the thing though.
At least with me, there was this like,
because it was a boys school,
but there was this
whole, I guess stigma of-
- People who dress well.
- Oh, if you dress well
then your gay. (laughs)
- Right.
- Like that whole shit.
- Right, right.
- So I think people just...
I'm sure there were boys
who actually did give a shit
about fashion and didn't-
- And didn't want it.
- But they didn't want to
because they were probably
worried about getting beaten up
and I get that.
It's like, yes, a fedora
might seem quite fashionable,
in the common eye but
why would you wear that
if you don't wanna get bullied?
- Yeah, true.
- I like wearing fedoras.
I think they look fucking
cool with the right outfit.
(laughs)
But the problem is a lot of-
- I'ma agree with Joey here.
Really?
- Yeah.
- I feel like the big problem with fedoras
is that the fucking neck
beard community just ruined,
completely ruined their image.
- This is like the Hitler mustache.
You can't wear it because
Hitler's ruined it.
- Well, exactly.
- It's the same thing with
the fedora, you can't do it,
'cause everyone's like incel
if they see you wearing it.
- That's the thing.
That's the thing.
But that's the problem.
I feel that a lot of
the reasons why fedora
is just commonly seen as
that type of negative thing
is because the hat itself is fine.
It's what you pair it with
that just makes it look
like absolutely dog shit.
- Well, you're either gonna
look like a neck beard
or you're gonna look like
a rip off Michael Jackson.
There's no in between.
- Right.
- I'd rather look like
a ripoff Michael Jackson
than a fucking neck beard, right?
(laughing)
But I've seen-
- Then you can truly enjoy
your lonely life (indistinct).
I'm out.
(laughs)
- I've seen fashion magazines
of dudes who wear a fedora
or a hat of some kind
that's similar to a fedora
in a really nice suit.
- Yeah.
- And they can match
that shit really well-
- Yeah, but those are the most
fucking attractive men on the planet.
- But that's what I'm saying, right?
And that's the other problem,
is that there are no attractive
men who wear fedoras.
(laughing)
I'm just saying.
I'm just preaching to the choir right now.
But you know that's true.
- I'm not gonna lie and pretend
I know how fashion works,
you know what I mean?
But-
- I'm no fucking fashionista.
- We're not fashion experts here.
- Thailand next top model.
(laughs)
- Fucking Steve Hanjobs is like,
let me teach you about fashion.
- I feel like having
that one kid in school,
who elevated the game really fucking-
- Elevated the game.
- He elevated the game
in school.
- He was the bench mark.
(Joey laughs)
He was the trend bro-
- He's really make me look fucking bad.
When he turns up with his
jeans with holes in them,
I'm like, how can we compete?
I don't have holes in my jeans.
- Oh, wait, because-
- What am I supposed to do?
- Wait, because you guys
didn't wear school uniforms?
- No we did.
- We wore school uniforms.
- And we had some days where
you would pay for charity.
- Yeah.
- You would pay like a pound
to dress in normal clothes.
Why do we do that?
- Right.
- I don't know.
(laughs)
So yeah, we have this thing
in UK schools-
- You had that as well right?
- Yeah, called own clothes day.
- Yeah, that's it.
- Right, own clothes day.
Where we have one day in
the term or something,
where we could just come
in in our own clothes.
- I hated-
- And we had to pay a pound.
- Yeah, we had that.
- I was speaking to Sydney and apparently
in her high school, they
didn't have school uniform.
- No.
- Yeah, they just-
- 'Cause American high
schools don't wear uniforms.
- Yeah, yeah.
- School uniforms are big brain,
because you always wear
the same shit every day.
- Yeah.
- Right, it's great.
- You don't have to worry
about like, oh, I wore the
same T-shirt for three days
in a row.
Because, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's a big reason
why I didn't give a shit
about fashion until later in life.
Was just because most days of the year,
I was wearing a fucking school uniform.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Although I say that, the fashion...
Whoever designed my school uniform
deserves a slap because...
(Connor laughs)
Okay, so in our high
school there's a set piece
that you have to wear from
when you're seventh grade
to 10th grade.
And then when you enter
11th and 12th grade,
you're like senior.
So you get to wear a senior
blazer and long pants
and shit like that.
The senior uniform is fine.
It looks dope as fuck.
It's basically just a suit,
essentially.
- Right.
- But the junior uniform is a little,
because for one, everyone
has to wear shorts.
(Garnt laughs)
- [Connor] Okay.
- Because, it's hot most
of the year in Australia,
so you wear shorts.
But then on top of that,
you have to wear long socks.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
I'm talking like up to the
fucking knee long socks.
- Like anime girl long socks, right?
- Like anime girl longs,
these gray knitted long socks.
- Someone had a fetish.
- Yeah, someone had a fetish.
So, basically there's just
these seventh to 10th grade kids
running around with
basically just only showing
their fucking knee.
- Was your school run
by Herbert the pervert
or something?
- I don't know.
I mean...
(laughing)
- Okay.
- I'm not gonna get into that.
(laughing)
But yeah, so I fucking hated that.
And, of course, because I
went to a private school,
if you didn't wear your thing properly,
you get a fucking punishment.
So it was like you just-
- Look at this private school boy.
- It's like, oh, I can see your shins.
You're gonna get a fucking slap for that.
You pull your socks up.
Was like, yeah.
(whooshing)
This episode is sponsored
by Honey.
- We all shop online.
- [Joey] And we've all
seen that promo code field
taunt us at checkout.
But thanks to Honey, manually
searching for coupon codes
is a thing of the past.
Honey is the free browser extension
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one
it finds to your cart.
- [Connor] Honey supports
over 30,000 online stores
that range from food delivery
to popular fashion brands.
- [Garnt] Imagine you're shopping
on your favorite online sites.
When you check out, the
Honey button drops down,
and all you have to do
is click apply coupons,
wait a few seconds as honey
searches for all the coupons
they can find for that site.
- And if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch those prices drop.
- So, what did you save money on guys?
- Pizza.
- How much did you save Joey?
- About $15.
- [Connor] Damn.
- Yeah, it was actually
good investment, yeah.
- [Connor] To convince
you go download Honey.
- I couldn't have done it without Honey.
- That's better than the
supermarket meal deal from Britain
that we always get.
(laughs)
- I won't hear about this blasphemy.
Honey has found it's
over 17 million members,
over $2 billion in savings.
If that's not stonks,
I don't know what is.
- [Joey] That is stonks as fuck.
- If you don't already have Honey,
you could be straight up
missing on free savings.
These are free.
It is 100% free guys.
- Why would you not take the free money?
- In a few seconds, as well.
- And by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and supporting this podcast.
And why would you not wanna do that?
- So, you should maybe get Honey for free
at joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
- Back to the episode.
(whooshing)
So in British schools it
goes, secondary school...
No, primary school, then secondary school,
then sixth form, right?
- Which is part of
secondary school normally
- Yeah.
Kind of, kind of.
So like our high school
is secondary school
and sixth form put together.
That's like the same-
- Why does it skip from two to six?
- No, no, okay so, it's
called secondary school,
'cause it's the second
school that you go to.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And then you start at
age 12 and then you can...
Oh, it's mandatory now, right?
You have to do sixth form now, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So it used to be, you could leave at 16
and you could go and work or
you can get an apprenticeship.
And then there's always an optional,
if you want to go to university,
you have to stay an extra two years.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which normally has about,
at least in my school
half the kids left at 16.
- Yeah, so in Australia
that would be junior high
and senior high.
- Right.
- Okay, okay.
- So it's like we have high school...
So, we have primary school
and high school, as well.
And high school's from
seventh grade to 12th grade.
- Seventh grade when
you're like age 12, 14?
- 13.
- 13?
Okay, okay, okay.
- And then you can leave at year 10,
which is like I guess the end
of secondary for you guys.
- Yes.
- And then the last two years
is senior high school.
- And that's like 16 to 18?
- And that's 16 to 18 then you go to uni.
- Yeah, so that's what
it's like in the UK.
- [Joey] Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I get it.
- And when I was in sixth form,
so I was in my last two years,
they tried to introduce
the school blazers,
'cause we didn't wear blazers.
- Yeah, we had blazers.
- But we were a public school,
so blazers were like, get a
load of these (indistinct).
(laughing)
And there was outrage
because they were like,
because, right.
Here's the thing, the school uniform,
you can only buy from
a special place, right?
You can just get it on Amazon.
- Right, right, right.
- And they were charging
70 pounds for the blazer.
- [Joey] Right.
- And obviously
this is a public school and
70 pound's like 100 bucks.
And for some parents
it's like way too much.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, they were like,
"What the fuck?
"No, we don't want a fucking blazer."
And there was a whole outrage about it.
And then eventually they
were like, fine, fine.
Okay, because the older kids are leaving,
they don't need to wear blazers.
So, I didn't have to wear one.
So, it's very fun watching-
- So wait,
it wasn't mandatory for you guys?
- It was mandatory.
- So what was
your school uniform?
- It was just a tie-
- So in England, we call
sixth form college as well.
Which gets a bit confusing when-
- Oh really, that's weird.
- When we say college, we mean
sixth form most of the time.
- But you can go to college?
- You can go to actual college.
- No, where college isn't college.
College in the UK is
one or two years, right?
Of a specialized thing
that you can then use
to then go in the University.
- Oh, we call that something different.
- No, we have that college.
That's college.
- Yeah, but we have sixth form college
and then we have whatever
preschool university.
Is that called college, as well?
- I believe those two are
the same institutions,
if I'm correct, or someone
could (indistinct).
- Because in Australia, we
don't even call it college.
We don't use that word.
- Well, what college is...
That's why when an American say,
"Are your going to college?"
No, no, no.
We're going to university.
(laughing)
- Yeah, we go to uni.
- It's like the Winnie
Poo meme where it's like,
college, university.
- College, university.
(laughing)
- Because college is
something entirely different
to British people.
- Yeah, yeah. It is.
- Yeah, anyway they were outraged.
So, half the school didn't
have to fucking wear blazers
and half the young kids did.
- Right, right, right.
- So, that was fun.
And you could just be like,
look at this fucking little 10-year-old
wearing his little blazer.
(laughing)
- No, we fucking loved the blazer.
The blazer was the bit.
- I don't wanna wear a blazer.
'Cause you weren't supposed to,
but the teachers got
so fucking done with it
that you can just wear hoodies
of your school uniform.
- Really.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Man, they must have like,
where are the rules in this school, man?
- For us in the winter,
if it was just a regular
white T-shirt underneath,
it'd be way too fucking cold.
- Yeah.
- So, sometimes you'd have
to wear the blazer just to stay warm.
Because the other option
we had was this like...
Our school colors were black and red.
So, we had this-
- What are you, fucking like
the evil school in Hogwarts?
- Yeah, right?
So, it was black and red.
So we had this like, if you
didn't wanna wear a blazer,
you had to wear this
fucking bright red, white,
like woolen fucking sweater.
- Yeah, we had something
like that, but it was green,
like moss green.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But like-
I know the exact color.
- But ours was bright red,
like the reddest red you can think of.
So you just fucking stick
out in a crowd, right?
- But at least you had pretty colors.
Ours was drab purple.
- Yeah, but the problem was is that,
because it was like a wool
thing, it was so fucking itchy.
It doesn't matter how many
times you wash that shit.
You're just like, fuck, I'm warm, but, ow!
(laughs)
Fuck this!
So, people were just like, fuck it.
I'm just gonna spend the
100 bucks on the blazer,
'cause I don't wanna wear this itchy ass
fucking like grandma's sweater shit.
(laughs)
- 'Cause I remember in my sixth form,
I knew I was a fucking
grown up in my sixth form.
- Yes.
(laughing)
- All right Garnt, all right.
- We went to the coolest sixth form,
because they let us wear our own clothes.
- Oh, wow.
- Ooh la la.
- This was the big thing.
We were allowed to call our
teachers by their first name.
- Oh!
- And that was like
bringing you up to the next level, man.
- Dude, we could only do that,
but It was a fucking Kaigi
gamble every time, right?
(laughs)
It was like, fuck, do I call you Mr. Smith
or do I just call you James?
- Yes I remember one student
did that in my class,
and he immediately like, "What
the fuck did you call me?"
(laughing)
He basically said that-
- I've heard that
so many times.
(laughs)
It's basically towards
the female teachers.
It's like, excuse me, Margaret.
And she's just like, what the
fuck did you just call me?
(laughing)
- Holy shit.
Bro, I remember....
I'm sorry, I just had this
flashback to something.
- Okay.
- I remember I did like...
So we had to do a presentation during...
Do you have registration in Australia?
- For what?
- Where you basically,
when you get to school,
you'd had a separate
class for registration
to say that you're here
and you've arrived in school.
- Oh, like orientation,
stuff like that?
- I guess yeah, orientation
for maybe Americans.
It's like a quick 15 minute thing
where everyone just goes and says
oh, I'm here.
- Oh, yeah.
Oh fuck, I forgot what that was called.
It was called like...
- Is that registration?
- That's what we called it in my school.
- Home class?
- We had a (indistinct) for it.
- Right, right.
- Homeroom, that's it.
That's what it called it.
- Homeroom? That's American.
Fuck Joey.
- Yeah, yeah.
No, we called it homeroom, yeah.
- At my school, we just call
it registration in English,
but we had word for it that I forgot.
- Right.
- So I don't fucking know.
But we just do like a short presentation.
- [Joey] What?
- Between like...
It would always be one of
the student's presentation
each day.
- Why would you have
to do a presentation?
On what?
- Just about saying
you fucking learned.
It was just some (indistinct)
pretentious bullshit.
- What is that, at the start of the day?
- Yeah, you have to do
a quick presentation,
about something you've learned that day.
- Oh, my God, that sounds awful.
(chuckles)
- I was like 14, right?
And we all fucking hated it.
And this teacher was horrible.
So my best mate in school
had a really bad stuttering problem.
He got a lot better now,
but everyone loved this guy,
'cause everyone just
wanted to see him do well.
And this one teacher was
so fucking rude to him,
about his stutter, and everyone was like,
yo, all my homies hate that teacher.
So, we were all just like...
We all took it in turns
trying to see how much
we could troll in these presentations.
- Yeah.
(Joey laughs)
- I did a pro gamer move.
- Yeah.
- I was like,
you know what I'm gonna present,
9/11 conspiracy theories.
(laughing)
I shit you not.
- What?
- And I dead ass think I got
the teacher to believe me.
- [Joey] Right.
- So, I came in.
I was like, moon landing, fake.
(laughing)
But what is the biggest conspiracy theory?
I did like this, like Steve
Jobs in a Ted Talk, right?
(laughs)
I was like, listen, look at this.
I did the Wingdings thing
with the flight number.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I was like,
look, it's two towers
and the star of Israel,
I rest my case.
(laughing)
And everyone was like, "No way!"
'Cause everyone's like 14,
and the teacher wasn't really smart.
They were like, what the
fuck, this is insane.
Whoa!
It was just so fucking funny.
'Cause I never got told off for that.
- Really?
- No.
I think for some reason, I think,
they thought I was super
genuine about my belief of this.
But obviously-
- So, they didn't wanna
crush on your belief?
- You just said it was enough conviction
that they were like, he must be right.
He must be fucking right.
- It wasn't just like the Wingdings.
I think said a bunch of other stuff,
but that was the big piece
of evidence where I was like
(claps) look, Microsoft planned 9/11.
(laughing)
- [Joey] That's so fucked.
- Dude, I do not know how
I got away with doing that,
'cause that is bad.
- Yeah.
- Fucking hell.
- I don't know how-
- We didn't do anything
during homeroom.
- No?
- I feel like the school
just implemented that to give the teachers
their 15 minutes smoke break
before the beginning, right?
- 'Cause our teacher
was the one who did it,
'cause we didn't have
any lessons with her.
She was always that one that goes like,
"You should be constantly
learning and advancing yourself."
I'm like, hell no, I wanna play
Modern Warfare Two at home.
I don't wanna fucking prepare.
- Dude, for us, homeroom
was just coming together
and just fucking getting
on our shitty iPhone 3S
and playing Doodle Jump together.
That was the only thing we did.
- I'm wondering if we...
I don't think I even had a
homeroom segment or session.
- Segment of the episodes.
- This is a segment.
- Segment of the fucking
school day or whatever
you wanna fucking call it.
- Garnt thinks it was
life in episodes.
(laughing)
- The homeroom mark.
- Season one, season two.
- Oh, my God.
- Yeah, I didn't have anything like that.
But yeah, let's talk
about some current topics
that aren't just nostalgic
trips back to high school,
right?
- We talk about high school
and shit so much but we
(indistinct) fucking funny stories.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- It's the prologue to our lives.
- It's great memories.
People listening to this
who are still in high
school, wouldn't understand.
But once you're out of high
school, you'll understand.
You'll look back on them.
- God, I was such a little shit.
- You sound like such
a grandpa saying that.
You'll look back to your high school
one day.
- I remember back in the day
when we only had three phones.
(laughing)
No, but, what's the...
I guess the big news quote, unquote.
- Other than "Attack on Titan."
- Yeah, other than "Attack
on Titan," of course,
everyone's fucking-
- Probably gonna be old news
by the time this episode airs.
- Yeah, everyone's fucking loving that.
But I guess like some news
that is more industry-driven
is the whole Funimation and
Crunchyroll thing, right?
- Got bought up by Sony.
Big cardy Sony.
- Sony buying out Crunchyroll.
- Yeah.
- And basically having control
of most of the big anime companies.
- Basically, just monopolize
the Western market.
- I mean, it is slightly worrying
when you hear that initially, right?
- Yeah.
- You're like, that's a lot
of market share that Sony has.
- Yeah.
- At what point would it
be considered a Sony like,
I guess a monopoly if
they had Netflix, right.
- Yeah, I feel like if
they had Crunchyroll,
Funimation, and Netflix, then-
- Then it would be like
game over-
99% basically.
'Cause basically, I think
the only other company
is probably Sentai
Filmworks who do Hidive.
And-
- Yeah.
Is Hidive still going?
- Hidive's still going.
- Shit.
(laughing)
- Fuck, Hidive.
I'm so sorry, I didn't know.
I guess it's just not available
outside the US, right?
So it's-
- No, it's available in the UK, as well.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
- Fuck, I didn't know that.
- But the problem with Hidive
is that I don't know how many
big exclusive titles that they have.
- I mean, how can you compete?
- 'Cause the only thing that I've watched,
the only big exclusive
I've watched of Hidive
is probably "Legend Of
The Galactic Heroes,"
and that's like
a fucking old, old...
- They did a new one.
- No, like the old one.
- Oh, the OG one, oh shit.
- So the only service
they have licensed, the OG
"Legend Of The Galactic Heroes."
- [Joey] Oh, wow.
- And I feel like...
I don't how many other exclusives
they have outside of that
that I can't get on.
- I've never used Hidive,
so I couldn't tell you
- Yeah, 'cause I know
"Made in Abyss," I watched
that on Amazon Strike.
back when that was a thing.
- Amazon Strike.
- Remember Amazon Strike?
(claps)
(laughs)
- Have Amazon stopped buying anime now?
'Cause I don't know what
anime they're getting anymore.
Have they got anything?
- No, they're still getting.
- The problem with
Amazon, is that they can-
- They buy one big show.
- Like last year they had "Vinland Saga."
But the big problem with
Amazon is that they sometimes
get big shows, but I fucking-
- They don't know how to market it.
- I fucking hate watching anime on Amazon,
because I don't know what shows
they have half of the time.
- Right, right, right.
- They actually have
quite a lot of anime,
but nobody knows about this
'cause nobody fucking
watches anime on Amazon.
- Yeah, not to mention that, I think,
the general problem with Amazon is that
they don't know how to market it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You find out, usually,
second hand from someone
who's like, "Oh, I watch
"Vinland Saga" on Amazon."
And you're just like,
"Vinland Saga" is Amazon.
What the fuck?
I mean, Amazon is "Vinland
Saga," what the fuck?
- Yeah.
- Actually, watching it isn't bad.
The play is really good.
And I don't know like what
fucking conversion they're using,
but man, it looks crisp as fuck
when you play it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But God damn is it horrible
to use their fucking platform?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Holy shit, dude.
I'm like, am I renting this
shit or am I streaming it?
It's not clear half
the fucking time?
- Exactly, exactly.
- Is like, I didn't mean to rent "Bora."
Why am I watching "Bora."
(Joey laughs)
I try to watch fucking anime.
What the fuck, Amazon?
And then also, because now obviously
I'm using Amazon Prime in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Amazon did that fucking pro gamer move,
of being like, yeah, no
subtitles for other languages
outside of this country.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah>
- Yeah.
- So, if I wanna watch
it, I have to buy Prime,
which I have in Japan, and
Prime in the UK or the US,
which is just fucking stupid.
- Does Prime even work for you here?
Like UK Prime work for you here?
- No, you can't do that.
- 'Cause it doesn't work for me.
- No, no you need to use...
You have Prime, but it's
probably Japanese Prime,
which doesn't offer any English subtitles.
- Yeah.
- And obviously, because their like,
we don't want people going
on to other countries
and buying stuff, which
kind of makes sense.
But also why, who cares?
(scoffs)
- It's 2020, I don't
know why licensing laws
haven't caught up to the fact that
it's a global fucking media now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- If you're gonna limit it to one country,
people are gonna find a way to
find other ways to watch it,
because people are gonna
watch it whatever happens.
- Like most people,
cause I see these threads
on Reddit where they're like,
"Bro if you buy Netflix now in Turkey
"you can get it for like $2."
And I'm like, but that seems
like a lot of fucking effort.
(laughing)
Do I really care that much
to go through all this (indistinct).
- I'm glad that if I
put all that effort in,
I can save a whole $4.
- Yeah.
- And then you gotta keep
using a VPN when you log in
and do that shit anyway.
- So you're only pay for
the VPN anyway. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- And like it's not worth
the fucking effort, man.
Do I really need this?
No, I don't.
Who cares?
The country that I'm in,
I don't wanna have to
fuck around with VPNs.
Don't make this hard for me.
- Yeah.
- And Amazon, obviously made it...
They're like, how do we
make it as hard as possible
in every single (indistinct)?
- So that no one use it.
- Yeah, how do we make it so that
you accidentally buy a dildo
instead of watching "Vinland Saga."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's basically like
every Amazon Prime experience.
- Do we have any like, I guess,
'cause there is very little information
about the whole Sony acquisition, right?
- Yeah, it's still very early days now.
- Wait, Meilyne, how much was it for?
How much was, 'cause we don't know.
- [Meilyne] Funimation buying...
Sony buying Funimation or
Sony buying Crunchyroll?
- Both.
- [Meilyne] So Sony, when they bought 95%
of Funimation in 2017 it
was around 143 million.
- 143.-
- Oh, that's right,
they did do that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 143?
- For Funimation.
- Yes.
- [Meilyne] For Crunchyroll
it's around 1.2 billion.
- Fuck!
Wasn't Amazon only like 900 million when-
- Can you say that number again.
- [Meilyne] 1.2 billion.
- $1.2 billion.
(indistinct)
That's more than Amazon bought Twitch for.
- Twitch for, yeah.
- Jesus Christ!
- Wow.
- Oh, my God!
- The question
that I wanna know-
- 143 for Funimation.
- Yeah, yeah.
That's already surprising,
but the biggest question I have is like,
all right cool, Sony you
have all this fucking money
to spend on Crunchyroll and
Funimation, that's fine.
But in my opinion, it's just like
what are you gonna do with it?
Is the question.
- [Connor] I mean, I guess-
- Because when Sony back
in the day bought the 95%
of Funimation or whatever it was,
not gonna lie, they didn't
really do much with it.
- Yeah, I haven't seen much
of a change from Funimation.
I don't know how well
Funimation was doing back then.
- Right.
- But it seems like
they've just gone on
business as usual, now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- 1.2 billion for
Crunchyroll, just kinda sees
how much they're investing
in anime, I guess.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because they must see the potential
in the anime industry to get to like
chill out this big of a market share.
- I guess, maybe they're willing
to throw that much money,
because they realized that
there is a massive competitor
now, and that is Netflix.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I guess when you put it into perspective
of like Twitch was bought
out, but that was like,
how many years ago was
Twitch bought out by Amazon?
- Probably around the same time
that Sony first bought Funimation.
- No it was earlier than that.
- Was it?
- I think it was
like 2016, right?
It must've happened, 2015.
- Really?
- Yeah, but still-
- When did they happen
Meilyne, can you Google it?
- Yeah.
- 2014.
Okay to be fair-
- But still Twitch was like
the fucking big shit back then.
- [Meilyne] Twitch was 970 million.
- Yeah, so Twitch was 970 million.
- But I guess Twitch in 2014,
I understand it really makes sense.
Twitch nowadays is pretty
worth like, five, six times.
Is that right?
- Oh, easily. Yeah.
- Yeah, I would say that, you know-
- Twitch at that point is-
- Comparing Crunchyroll
now to Twitch back then-
- Twitch is still bigger I'd say.
- I would say Twitch was a whole property,
'cause everyone was expecting
YouTube to buy Twitch.
I remember back in the day
where it was just like-
- Yeah, that's right.
- Where it was just like, yeah,
everyone's like, well,
Google is gonna buy Twitch,
that's just a natural move,
right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it was a big surprise when Amazon
kind of stepped in.
- And then Jeff Bezos
was like, "JK.
(laughing)
"I'ma step in."
- That's been great for creators, though.
- Yeah.
- That, that happened.
But I'm curious as to why...
Do you have any thoughts of might why
this might be good or bad for anime fans
in general?
(Joey sighs)
- It just-
- I mean, I'd say
as a consumer, it would
probably be better.
Because, okay-
- For more money in the
industry is always better.
- Well, it's not only that,
but I remember I would say the golden age
of anime streaming was...
Remember when you could get every anime
you could conceivably want
to watch on one platform,
which was Crunchyroll back in the day?
And then it kinda just like got spread out
to different streaming companies.
- I mean that was inevitable
that it was gonna happened.
- It was inevitable.
The biggest thing I find annoying,
isn't just the fact that I have to pay
for different streaming companies.
It's just the fact that nowadays
when I go through an anime char,
I literally have no idea which anime
is gonna be in which platform.
- Yeah.
- That's true, that's true.
- Unless it's specifically
says like Prime,
for example.
- Yeah.
I just want to log onto one service
and be like, okay, I just wanna...
Don't care how much I'm
paying for this service,
I just want to watch all
the anime I want to watch
in that one service.
- Well, it's confusing 'cause
I thought "Jujutsu Kaisen,"
is that correct?
- Yeah.
- Was on Netflix.
- No, that was on Crunchyroll.
- It's on Crunchyroll.
- But it is on Netflix.
- [Joey] Is it?
- In Japan? (chuckles)
- No, in Japan.
- Oh, in Japan.
- So, it's really
confusing living in Japan.
'cause I'm like, wait, who owns what?
Because of Japan and like...
Because obviously it's pretty
much Japan, rest of the world.
That's how the anime market works, right?
- Yeah.
- Obviously.
And it's really confusing.
So I'm like, wait, where
do I watch it though?
I realized Netflix doesn't
offer English subtitles
probably for that reason
with the licensing, right?
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- Fuck, it's a mess though.
It is a mess.
- Yeah.
- It's like, how do I know
where to fucking watch
and what?
(Joey laughs)
- And then everyone's
just laughing being like
(laughs), "Piracy."
Like TDXT.
- Yeah, of course.
- I wanna pay, I want an easy service.
- I want a convenience service.
I'm willing to pay for
a convenient service,
which for the longest time
it was until it wasn't.
And now it's like I wanna
support the industry,
but at the same time,
if I'm having trouble
finding which service
has got which anime,
I literally have to...
There is a dedicated
search engine for this.
I think the name is like
Because Moe or something,
that's the name of the website.
That's literally a dedicated search engine
to search which anime is
on which streaming service.
- I love that someone had to make that.
- Yeah, I know, right?
- That really is telling-
- It's like this fucking
pre-order like a spreadsheet.
Like what do you get in what pre-order
it's like a fucking know what's on what.
Fuck me.
- Well then would you say
then in that instance that,
I guess a full monopoly
of the Western market
onto one service is a benefit.
- I mean it's not the
monopoly though, is it really?
Because Netflix is.
- Right, but that's
what I'm saying though.
Like if, for example-
- Yeah, monopoly is always bad.
- Yeah, but that's what I'm saying.
But for example, if Sony,
hypothetically is like,
hey, we wanna buy the anime side of things
from the Netflix's, right?
That would truly, I would
say, turn it into a monopoly
at least in terms of the Western market.
- That'd be awful.
- That would basically
be a monopoly at that point.
- That'd be awful for anime fans though.
- Yeah, it'll be awful for anime fans,
but at the same logic
that Garnt was saying,
it would all be on one platform too.
- That's kinda like the
fucking Disney argument,
now, isn't it?
- Right.
- Like, yes, all my characters
now are gonna be in the MCU.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yay for monopoly, right?
- [Joey] (scoffs) Oh my God.
- Because (indistinct), right?
It's like with the whole Disney shit
it's worrying because if
everything's on fucking Disney,
we only get Disney ass products.
- Right.
- I don't want
fucking Disney shit.
I fucking hate Disney movies.
- That remind me of other
day when I was streaming,
I don't know how true this is,
so take this with a grain of salt.
But somebody was saying
that there's a rumor
that Disney might be
acquiring "Shonen Jump."
- Oh, my God. No, no.
- Please no, please.
No, seriously.
- I don't know how true that is.
- Fact-check this Meilyne.
- Please, can you fact check this because-
- Fact check.
- Because he sounded
pretty fucking convincing
when people in the chat
were talking about it.
But apparently, Disney
is thinking to acquire it
because they want to do
a collaborative thing
between "My Hero Academia" and the MCU.
- No.
- And I'm just in my head-
- That's gotta be a fucking troll though.
No way.
- If it is a troll, then-
- That's gotta be a troll.
- That sounds like a meme.
- If it's a troll than
I've fallen for the bait.
But at the same time,
I wouldn't be surprised
if Disney actually wanted do that.
- I cannot stand Disney.
- Because, think about it.
It's like MCU, super heroes,
"My Hero Academia," super heroes.
It's a match made in Heaven
according to Disney, right?
- Right, I can't wait
for when fucking Omai
shows up in "Avengers Five"
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Oh my-
- I don't see it.
- You don't see it?
- All right Joey's bullshitting.
It is bullshit.
- Maybe I'm using
the wrong keywords.
- Okay.
- Oh, my God, you know what
that would mean though?
The fucking Thanos versus
Goku memes like become real.
(laughs)
And become like a
legitimate talking point.
- It would be horrible for
like a realistic standpoint.
But my God the amount
of shit post and memes
that would come out of
this will be fucking epic.
Again, take it with a grain of salt.
It might be a troll.
It might just be-
- Joey's talking
out of his ass.
- I might be talking out of my ass.
I don't know.
- You are.
- That just means every MCU conversation,
would end with, both Goku
could beat. (chuckles).
- But Goku could beat Captain America.
(laughing)
- But could Goku beat HIV.
I already liked the way Disney
does things with properties
and it's worrying that
they're acquiring so much.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- They have so much control over things,
because yeah, Disney movie
is streamlined and it's nice,
but you don't get the
weird shit from Disney.
- Right.
- You don't (indistinct) shit.
- That's what I'm saying.
When I heard about that
supposed rumor, or bullshit,
or whatever it was, I wasn't immediately,
oh, that's bullshit.
That's never gonna happen.
Because there is a very likely chance
it very much might happen.
- Yeah.
- And if it does happen,
then it's gonna be really bad for anime.
Anime is gonna get fucking
boring when that happens.
- I mean, what I would saying now is that
so we can basically break
down the main plays to be,
Crunchyroll, Funimation, Netflix of...
Crunchyroll, Funimation and Netflix,
and there's Sentai Filmwork
doing their own thing.
- Yeah.
- But I will say that
putting those two together,
they do have very different brands.
Sometimes you watch an
anime and you're like,
yeah, this feels like a Netflix show.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- "Beastars" felt like
it belonged to Netflix.
- Yeah.
- "Devil May Cry" maybe felt
like it belonged on Netflix.
What I always say when it was
Crunchyroll versus Funimation
is that they have exact same branding.
So, I'm just like, oh,
"Kaguya-sama" is on Crunchyroll,
then on Funimation like what?
Season two is on Funimation.
'Cause they were both trying
to acquire the same show.
- It's the same type of consumers, I feel,
that use both Funimation and Crunchyroll.
And not to say that Crunchyroll
users don't use Netflix
and vice versa.
But I feel that, yeah, as you said,
there's a certain, I don't
know what the right word
for it is.
Edginess when it comes
to shows on Netflix?
- [Garnt] I don't know.
- I don't know what the
right word for it is.
- Netflix is that cooler older brother
who comes in and is like, hey,
you ever played a game boy?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
(laughing)
You know what I mean, like that vibe.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We've obviously done
work with Netflix, so.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- But this is totally separated from that.
But I mean their service is the best, man.
I mean, obviously the Netflix
jail stuff fucking sucks.
Sometimes, at least in Japan,
the subtitle differences,
again, those we obviously know.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- That sucks, but you use that player
and it's like, you can't beat that shit.
- [Joey] No, no.
- You can download it,
and now you can do audio only on a mobile,
which I love.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you used to have to keep...
When I used to listen to stuff on Netflix,
I used to keep my phone open in my pocket,
like the screen going.
- Yeah.
- But now you can just do
audio only.
And it's like, oh, my God!
It's like they know what I fucking want
before I do it.
- Okay, but the question
is then, what would you watch?
What kind of content would
work for audio only stuff.
Like documentary's.
- It's not about that.
It's just sometimes I'm
in a situation where I-
- I couldn't do that for anime, honestly.
- No, I'm in a situation where
I can't look at my screen
for like just two minutes,
'cause maybe I'm getting off the train,
maybe I'm walking around real quick.
I just wanna lock my phone.
But I wanna keep listening,
I just got my headphones on.
- I get you.
- So it's just, quick little moments
where you just wanna turn it off,
but you don't want content to just stop.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah.
Honestly, the big thing for me for Netflix
is the skip opening button.
- Skip opening.
- Yeah.
- They've also just added
the two times speed, 1.5-
- Oh, really?
- So now you can decide
if you wanna be a bastard and watch anime
at two times speed.
(Joey laughs)
- I know it's a fucking
cardinal sin to say
you could skip opening
anime openings, but-
- I skip them.
- That's made it so much more easier
to watch some of the anime.
'Cause let's be honest, let's be honest.
- They do it automatically for endings.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You can physically
tell them, no, no, don't.
'Cause every time "The
Great Pretender" ended
I'm like, no, let me listen.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- [Joey] I love this song.
- I fucking love this.
- No, no, no.
Sometimes you do watch the ending,
and sometimes you do
listen to the opening.
- Yeah.
- But let's be honest,
most of the time you
wanna skip the opening.
You watch the opening ones
and it's another generic
J-pop opening.
- It's a binge.
- Especially if you're
like binging.
- If its a binge.
- And I love binging anime.
I don't watch anime weekly.
So for me, unless it's a
fucking banger of an opening
which is there's always one
or two shows every season
but it's not every fucking show.
For me "Beastars" was one.
I always fucking listen
to the "Beastars" opening.
- "Beastars has a
fucking amazing opening,
"Mob Psycho" as well.
- I was like, no, no, no,
don't skip it.
(laughing)
Just leave it, Netflix, come on.
- Just let it play.
- Yeah, come on,
I wanna watch this.
Yeah, it's great.
- Yeah, like, you said,
"The Great Pretender" ending
which is like...
You've always got time
for Freddie Mercury.
- Come on.
- Come on, you've always got time-
- Never skip Freddie Mercury.
- What time is it?
I've got time, regardless.
You know what I mean?
(laughing)
And you can download episodes.
I know you could do that on
Crunchyroll now, I think,
if you pay extra.
- You can pay extra to
download in Crunchyroll.
I have never tried it
so I don't know how good
the services is.
'Cause I know you can do it on Funimation,
but it didn't work that good.
- That was always the biggest
complaint in Funimation,
is that the website was garbage.
- Yeah.
- As far as I wouldn't know,
I can't use it downloading the US.
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
- What do you think the plan is with Sony?
Why do you think they decided-
- That's a good question.
I have no fucking idea.
- 'Cause that's what
I've always wanted to know, again, right?
It's like, what is it about
Crunchyroll and Funimation
that Sony was like, "We'll
drop a billion bucks on this?"
- Sony has a movie division.
- Right.
- It's pretty,
I think a big part of their business.
- So do you think we'll start
to see maybe like funding
Sony Original anime on
Crunchyroll and Funimation maybe?
- Maybe, I don't know.
- 'Cause they have to compete
with Netflix Originals, right?
- Yeah, right now Sony already
own the production committee
to a lot of anime.
- Yeah.
- Including like big animes
like I think isn't it
like "The Demon Slayer?"
- Oh yeah, they could be.
- Kinda funded "Demon Slayer"
because that's Aniplex, right?
- I have no idea.
- Yeah.
- Actually I might be
talking out of my ass here.
- Which company does Sony own?
Is it Aniplex?
- Aniplex, yeah.
- Yeah Sony owns Aniplex.
- Oh, Aniplex is a lot of (indistinct).
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm pretty sure Aniplex
was with "Demon Slayer."
- Yeah.
- They're usually
with the majority of the big shonen.
- It only makes sense so they'd wanna
get a big grip on the Western market.
I mean, if you're funding this shit,
you already have a lot
of say over it, right?
- I think right now, I don't
know what their plans are,
but I think the amount of
money they threw at it,
just shows how much potential they see
for the anime market, right?
- Yeah, for real.
- Cause.
- It's a gold rush right now,
I think really.
I think all the companies
are fighting to get control
over the Western market
'cause they realized
this shit's big.
- It's like an IP race, right?
To see how many IP's they
can grab, essentially.
- While it's still young and
it still hasn't fully settled,
which is now.
Why wouldn't you just
throw money at the shit
and try and get all the IP's,
get all the foundation set up?
- True, true.
- Do you see anime becoming as big as,
say gaming or like other things
in a few years?
- I do, I do.
- Yeah.
- Maybe not like hentai, but-
- Yeah, maybe not-
- Hey man, hey man.
You just wait, you just wait boy.
You just wait.
- You just wait.
You just wait till I
drop my original hentai
and then we will see how big it gets.
(laughs)
- Listen, right?
Everyone watches porn, right?
- Yeah.
- But there isn't no like
Avengers of porn.
No, one's discussing like...
There's no podcast about porn.
I don't think, actually, maybe there is.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
There's no big discussions
about porn and like,
oh my God, who's Johnny
Sins gonna fuck next
on the next episode?
- Johnny Sins
is the Captain America of porn.
- It's not gonna be that Garnt,
get your hopes down now, all right?
- I don't know man, isn't like
Pornhub in like the top 20
most used sites.
- Well, they just gutted
their library.
- Yeah they just destroyed
like 60% of their library.
(whooshing)
This episode is sponsored
by EJ Anime Store.
Do you know what EJ stands for?
- [Connor] And so in Japan "Kamikawa's"
official online anime merch store
that delivers exclusive
merch to overseas anime fans
directly from Japan.
- Some of their products
are only available
for a limited time period,
so be sure to check the pre-order
deadline shown on screen
for each item.
So what have we got today?
- [Connor] The first figure
is the "Re:Zero" Petra Leyte
tea party version.
This figure includes an
exclusive bonus, gentlemen,
a letter written by the author
of "Re:Zero" light novels.
- Oh, Nagatsuki Tappei.
- [Garnt] A personal letter?
- Just to you.
- Thank you Nagatsuki sensei.
- Petra who newly joins
the Roswaal Mansion
in "Re:Zero" season two.
- There's also the "Made
in Abyss" Nanachi plushy.
This thing is actually really
fucking cute, I want it.
- Additionally today we have a bit
of a special introduction.
As some of you may know,
over the span of three days
at the end of November, we
released a series of streams
on each of our Twitch channels
as part of a speed run competition
in which we had to put together
one of the EJ Anime Store
plastic model kits,
which is this box here.
And we had to see who
could do it the fastest.
- Also known as the "Sword Art Online"
Figure-rise Standard Asuna Dengeki
pearl color limited version.
I said that in one take,
let's go.
- Oh, my God.
- And if you've already
watched the streams,
you already know who won and lost.
- Absolutely getting destroyed.
I thought I was fast,
and then Connor was like, no, no, no, no.
- Hold up.
- Hold it.
- Okay.
So I didn't know this
before, but we have a forfeit
that the loser had to do,
and Meilyne, is about to present to me
my forfeit.
- I've seen it.
I've seen it and it's gross.
(laughs)
So that's a black-
- Oh, that stinks.
- It's a black cobra chili.
- Meilyne, what the fuck
did you buy for me?
- No it's not a chili.
- What is this Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] That's a black cobra chili.
- Yeah, that is a black cobra chili,
right there.
- Meilyne, this is not
what we agreed to.
- (chuckles) What is this thing?
- That's a giant water bug.
(laughs)
- You should have gotten good.
- I'm not gonna fucking forget this.
(laughs)
This is Meilyne's idea, by the way.
Wasn't our idea.
Look at this shit.
Oh fuck, it's fucking awful.
(laughing)
- Oh, it just flipped over.
- Can you hold one up to the camera,
Joey?
- Yeah.
- That's disgusting.
- Oh, yeah.
- I would not wanna eat that.
Good luck Garnt.
So, while Garnt enjoys
on his fantastic meal
for the evening, EJ Anime
Store will be giving away
one lucky winner an Asuna figure set
with a wall scroll signed
by the three of us for free.
- Oh, shit, look at that.
- [Connor] What?
That's pov.
- [Joey] It's got our signatures on it.
- I have to act excited now.
- Look, it's the loser's signature.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, right in the corner.
- [Connor] All you simply have to do guys
is follow their Twitter @ejanimestore,
like and retweet their tweet that contains
the TTAsunaSpeedRun,
and then retweet the post.
(whooshing)
- It literally smells like swamp.
I was trying to figure
out what this smells like.
- You know what it smells like?
It smells like licorice.
- And once you do all that
you will have the chance to
win the Asuna plastic model
with the signed wall scroll, gentlemen.
- [Meilyne] Tear off it's
head, rip off it's wings
and squeeze it like a tube of.
(laughing)
- Wait, say that again.
- So, how do you eat this Meilyne?
- So you tear off it's head,
do you want me to do it for you?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You tear off it's head.
(laughs)
(Joey laughs)
- Oh, no.
- And then you take off it's wings.
(screaming)
- Oh!
- And then you just-
- Oh, there it is.
- Oh, fuck! (claps)
- I'm gonna fucking puke.
What the fuck.
(Joey laughs)
- You just give it a suck and that's it.
- What the fuck is that?
- Just give it that good suck.
Wait, can I smell it?
Ooh, that's strong, isn't it? (laughs)
- So, if you missed the stream,
watch the archive on our Twitch channels
as a reference to build your own model.
Both the regular version
and the special bonus
wall scroll set set will be available
on the EJ Anime Store website.
So, check the links in the description
to speedrun it yourself.
Please try and beat our times.
How is it Garnt?
How does it taste?
- He just spat it out?
- It has the worst fucking after...
(banging)
I need some...
Gimme this G Fuel, man.
- Wait, do you wanna-
- That is disgusting.
- Do you wanna eat the
cobra chili instead?
There you go, eat that.
(laughs)
- [Meilyne] That whole
thing is 60,000 units.
(Joey laughs)
- I'm fucking dying.
(dramatic music)
What the fuck?
Why did I just do that?
- That's what you get from
moseying around in a speed run.
- I wanted to get honestly-
- Oh God, I can smell
the chili from here.
- Honestly, the chili is like
a fucking breath of fresh air,
compared to what I tasted.
My mouth is on fucking fire right now,
but it feels better than
that fucking water bug, man.
- I don't know why, but
I kinda wanna try it.
Am I allowed to just try it?
- [Meilyne] Go for it,
there's three of them.
One for you-
- Oh, hey Connor, there's
one for you as well.
You want one?
- Oh, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I wouldn't
- So, what do you do?
You rip off the head.
- Rip off the head, take out the wings.
- So, wait, what is this used for?
What is this fucking thing-
- For food.
Oh God, that's very juicy.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
(whines)
It's like salty-
- Oh, God, look at that.
- [Connor] I don't wanna look at that.
Don't show me, don't pry it's
asshole open in front of me.
- Wait, let me try.
(soft instrumental music)
- [Connor] Oh, God, Joey.
- [Garnt] It literally
tastes like salty swamp.
That's literally what it like.
(laughing)
Did you spit it out?
Where did you spit it out?
- In the (indistinct).
- I just swallowed it.
- [Meilyne] Do you want a purin?
- Yeah, actually, you know what.
(laughs)
- Well, thank you EJ Anime Store
for sponsoring this
episode of the podcast.
- Fuck you Meilyne.
- Back to the episode.
- Fuck you!
(whooshing)
(whines)
- I'm fucking bored talking about anime.
(laughing)
Fuck anime.
- We're not even an anime podcast anymore.
- Imagine talking about
anime on "Trash Taste" guys.
- [Joey] Ew!
- I feel like I'm attempting
to be the Winnie The Pooh meme,
like the high class one
when I talk about anime.
I'm trying to form opinions.
I don't have opinions Joey.
(Joey laughs)
I don't have well formed-
- I just watch that shit.
- I don't have well formed
opinions about things.
- What, you think we do?
- I just say what I feel, okay?
- I mean, you don't have
well formed opinions
about anything-
- Fuck off, Garnt!
Fuck off!
- Anime, food, gaming.
- Oh, no.
- Let's be honest here,
let's be honest here.
- I went on a little run
on my stream the other day,
just being like, Garnt is actually like,
your parents didn't beat you enough.
(laughing)
- What?
- Because, right?
Listen, he was allowed to get away with
not eating crusts, right?
If I didn't eat my crust-
- Oh, I think I saw you
talking about that. (chuckles)
- If I didn't eat my crust right,
you know what my parents would do?
They'd be like, "That's fine, Connor,
"You have dinner ready for tomorrow now."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'll be like, but
mom, I don't want them.
She's like, "No Connor,
you're eating fucking crust.
"You're not wasting food?"
- Who says that I didn't get my ass beat
for not eating my crust?
- Did you?
Were you like fucking Spartacus,
like, mother I will not bow to the crust.
- Because I had gone my
entire fucking childhood
having to being forced to eat my crust.
So as soon as I was a fully
grown adult, who can make my own
fucking decisions.
- This is what I'm saying.
- I was like, mother, I do not
care what you think anymore.
I'm going to not eat my crust.
- I pay my own rent.
- I pay my own bills.
I buy my own food.
Fuck you mother.
(laughing)
- All I'm saying is you
should've got a backhand
a little bit more.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It should have been a little harder.
(laughs)
- That's such a bad joke, I'm so sorry.
- There is something that I
didn't fully appreciate as a kid
or like I didn't fully-
- Crust.
- No, not crust.
(laughs)
- Good food.
- Not crust, but like-
- We're not getting into food by the way.
- We're not getting into food again.
But I was yesterday
fucking cleaning the house
and I fucking hate cleaning the house.
(Joey laughs)
I don't think anyone in their entire life
likes cleaning the house.
And I didn't realize why
my parents fucking...
Basically just every parent
manipulates their kids
to be like their personal slaves.
- Do my job slave.
- When it comes to cleaning the house.
- Well, that's the reason why they used
to have so many kids, right?
And it was like, they got
to plow the fields, right?
I intend to keep that
British philosophy alive
when I have a kid.
- You need seven kids.
- He needs to plow the
fields, and clean the house,
and prepare the food.
- Yeah, Connor's gonna
like mean max that shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- All right, my house
has six rooms.
So that's six children,
I need to have, at least.
(laughing)
One per room.
- I'm not gonna beat my kids Valerie.
That was a distasteful joke.
Just saying that now.
- Yeah, 'cause why is
the activity of cleaning
just so awful.
(Joey laughs)
Does anyone...
Who actually enjoys cleaning the house?
- When you get rid of a lot of dirt,
that's why I let it build up.
I let it get gross.
- Right, right
- 'Cause when you clean
that shit, it's like
peeling off a good scab.
- All right,
- Its like, oh.
Oh, it's so clean.
- Yeah, but-
- I need to see
a physical layer of dust
in order for me to be like, yes.
- Dude when you swipe a
whole layer of dust off
with like a wet wipe or something,
damn that feels good.
That takes that (indistinct)
- I get like a quarter chub,
at least.
(laughing)
- But I don't like cleaning.
- No.
- No, because like,
yeah, that is a satisfying feeling.
But my problem with is
that cleaning just...
Shit I never knew as a kid how
much fucking time and effort
it takes to clean.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- Okay, when you're a kid,
you just clean your own fucking room.
You hoover the living room.
- I didn't even do that.
- Or whatever-
- I did that.
- Oh, you lucky motherfucker.
- Yeah.
- You lucky motherfucker.
- I would, but then five minutes later
it'd be back to where it was.
So my parents were just like, whatever.
- Like I still have
fucking Vietnam flashbacks
of my mom calling me like,
I know she's about to ask me
to hoover the living room,
I know it.
(chuckles)
I don't wanna come down right now.
- This time I'm having Vietnam flashbacks.
(laughing)
- But yeah, I realized as an adult
the act of cleaning just
like, it takes you all day.
And the reason I hate it
is because it feels like,
you know when you do something productive,
you do a hard day of work or something,
or like even playing a video game,
you feel like you're making
progress with your life.
- I don't know about the
video game thing, but-
- No, no, like when it...
Like for me, whenever I'm
playing like a first person game,
like a single-player game,
making progress with this story.
- Yeah, okay, okay, okay.
- Yeah something like that,
- I don't know about that.
(laughing)
- This guy.
- Like a JRPG, right?
- They're like a JRPG.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel you, I feel you.
- I love wasting my time.
- With cleaning, the whole..
The entire concept of cleaning is that
you're working towards
making things zero again.
You're working towards zero.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- You're working towards
making things normal again.
- Oh!
- Oh, what happened?
- Oh, it switched off?
- Sorry, Joey laptop is shit.
- But yeah, you're working towards making
the default state zero again.
- Right.
- And I'm just like,
this doesn't feel good,
yet it takes so much
time and energy to do it.
And no one prepared this for me as a kid.
- It's like shoveling
snow in a blizzard, right?
- Yeah, right.
- It's gonna form back up again.
So it's like, what's the point?
- I only used to clean on like...
This is how I would decide
if I'm gonna clean this day.
Is somebody coming to my house?
No, I'm not cleaning.
(Joey laughs)
Is somebody coming to-
- That is still my stay.
- Yeah, is somebody coming to my house?
Fine, I'll clean.
You know what the best
adult purchase I ever made
while I was in the UK?
- What?
- It was a good vacuum.
I was like, you know what?
What's all this hype
around here's Dyson things?
What is all that hype?
'Cause I lived with a friend-
- It's just a brand.
- Yeah, I lived with a
guy and his dad worked
for the Henry Hoovers.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know those
like the fucking...
The ones with a smiley face.
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Little smiley face?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I don't know if these are in America,
but their everywhere in the UK.
- Right.
- These things
they're like tanks, they don't die.
But they also kinda suck.
They don't suck good.
They should be sucking good.
(indistinct)
(Joey laughs)
And I'm like, this guy in my house,
I was like, I wanna get a Dyson.
And he was like, "No, no, no mate.
"No, no.
"All you need is this thing."
And he fucking slaps it.
He's like, "It's a fucking
unit, this thing is."
And I broke it within two weeks.
(laughs)
That's my own thought there.
- What the fuck did you suck up?
- The border.
(laughing)
- Well, that'll do it.
- I was like, oh no, I
have to get a new one.
Oh no.
- Oh, no there's a puddle,
quick grab the hoover.
- Oh no, I have to get a new vacuum.
Fuck.
(laughing)
No.
So I bought a Dyson, dude.
That shit cleaned up...
It could have, oh my God!
The carpet was a different color.
I was like, what have I been doing
my whole life?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I never believed in that Dyson shit too,
until I bought one a couple of years ago.
- Bro, it changes the game.
- Lets see how good these are?
And I do it, I was like, all right.
Not buying anything else anymore.
This is the one thing.
- You crank that shit up
to max suck and like, oh, my God.
- It gives the good suck.
- The shit.
- The max suck.
- Here's how I could...
Okay, this Dyson has all this bullshit
about rotating fucking
things like 10 cylinder.
It's a load of shit.
Let me say why it's good, right?
You know that one piece that always sticks
to the fucking carpet
that doesn't come off.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Dyson never has an issue
getting that one crumb
out of the carpet.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That shit always comes out.
'Cause the normal vacuums
they don't get that shit out.
- No.
- There's always that
one thing that for some
reason won't come out.
you gotta fucking-
- It's just like clinging onto the carpet
with dear life, right?
- And then you're like,
how many roll overs
am I gonna do this thing
until I just admit defeat,
bend over, pull out of the
carpet, like an animal,
and feed it into the vacuum
like it's some budget dog.
I'm like here you go, here you go.
Come on, take, take.
I don't like doing that.
- Yeah.
- I don't wanna do that.
I'm not a peasant.
I shouldn't have to touch
my carpet with my hands.
That's disgusting.
- Okay. (laughs)
- So yeah,
that's how I can sell it to you.
You will never have to bend over.
(laughing)
- You'll never have to bend to the knee.
- Dude, it's amazing, dude.
And that was my gift to my
parents when I went to Japan.
Obviously I couldn't bring it with me.
- Right.
- So I was like, parents,
you can have my priced possession.
- Here's a vacuum cleaner.
- [Joey] Here's a vacuum.
- I'm like bending over, like giving them
like the sword of Camelot.
Like, fucking here you go mother.
(laughing)
Take it.
Take my Dyson V12 max suck edition.
All right. (chuckles)
To be fair, she thought
it was all nonsense,
but she tried it.
She was like, "All right Connor,
"this is a pretty fucking good gift."
- Yeah, I get you.
- She was converted.
- You're welcome mum.
- Which is a lot like the biggest reason
I don't cook or I don't like cooking,
is because cooking...
I like cooking.
Cooking's great, I like the food,
Cleaning up, man.
It's like the ratio of
time it takes to clean up,
versus eating good food,
nice home cooked food,
it's not optimal.
It's so sub-optimized.
The entire activity of cleaning
is just sub optimized in life.
- You've become like
me, I swear, recently.
- No, no, no.
- You're caring about the
splits, the efficiency.
(laughs)
- Cleaning for me has
always been suboptimal.
I don't know why this is
the one activity in life
that it's just like, this
needs to be balanced.
There needs to be like
a balanced patch in life
that just makes cleaning less effort.
- It's like doing a 20-minute side quest
to get to a two-minute main question.
- [Garnt] Yeah because it-
- It just doesn't make sense.
- It takes more like...
it's a side quest that
takes more time and energy
than the fucking main quest.
You finish cleaning
(Joey laughs)
and you're like, all right,
time to get down to work.
- It's like cool, I'm
glad I spend 30 minutes
cooking this thing that
took me two minutes eat.
- Yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly, right?
- I order a lot of Uber Eats, obviously.
And I caved and in Japan
they have an Uber Eats pass,
where if you pay $9 a month,
you get free delivery fee.
So there's no delivery fee
which is like two bucks each time.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, fuck dude
am I really ordering this
much fucking take out?
And I was like, yeah, I am.
- Yeah.
- And then I did it
in my head, right?
I did this thing where for
three times when I cooked,
I timed it.
- Yeah.
- I didn't speed run it or anything.
I wasn't doing splits or anything.
I wasn't like-
- Expendedicts, 80%.
- Yeah, I was...
(laughing)
This is the onion split.
Oh, I got a gold onion split.
No, I wasn't doing that.
I just had a timer and I timed genuinely
how long it took, right?
- Yeah.
- And then I timed
cleaning up, right?
- Yeah.
- Because I wanted to know,
based on my average earnings
for a month, right,
(laughing)
is this technically, am I
losing money by cooking myself?
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- 'Cause I was like, this
is how I can scientifically
justify to myself ordering takeout.
- Right, right.
- Right?
So, I split it up, right?
I did the average...
No, I knew you guys would
fucking laugh at me for this.
- It's just hilarious that
you went to this effort.
- This is big brain.
- All right, well.
- Do it yourself, right?
Go home now.
- No, I don't have to
'cause you've done it for us, right?
- I do not enjoy cooking.
So that whole factor of enjoyment is gone.
That's not a factor of my decision.
- But do you enjoy the end result?
- I enjoy Uber Eats more.
(laughing)
- Bro you-
- No, there is something
about a home cooked meal.
I don't know what it is.
- Okay to be fair-
- 'Cause you can cook it
exactly the way you wanted to.
- There's a charm about a home cooked meal
if you know how to cook.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
My cooking's mixed.
- If you don't then its
just like punishment.
- You should try it sometimes Joey.
- No, no, I'm good.
- Just tell Akie to be like, yo.
- I only make like curry and Mexican.
That's all I make,
right?
- (chuckles) Right.
- Honestly, that's all
you need in my book.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
So Mexican food,
I can't really like make enough to store,
'cause it's really expensive,
the ingredients as well.
- Yeah.
- But curry, I can only make
like enough for like six meals.
And that's just pretty nice
'cause then that like the like time
versus money effort is fine.
But I don't cooking anything else,
because when I did this thing,
I found out that I was like wasting,
if you did the time to money conversion
on my earnings to like...
It was like 40% less efficient
to cook my own meals.
- Connor's got like a fucking
Spreadsheet (indistinct).
- Because it was driving me insane,
because I was speaking to some people
who were like this fucking
entrepreneur people.
They're like, "I never
cook or clean or any thing.
"I hire a maid, I get Uber Eats.
"I don't do any of that shit.
"It's a waste the time.
"I'm on that grind 24/7."
In reality, I would like an
extra hour to play video games
I'm not gonna lie.
(Joey laughs)
Because in my life, an extra
hour to play video games
it's quite a lot of time.
- Yeah.
- So if I can get
an extra hour playing video games
and then I can then later on
spend an extra hour working
it's like, okay, it makes
sense to just get Uber Eats
- Yeah.
- It's just Connor the podcast
trying to justify his spending.
Is that what this is?
- No, no, no, no.
- Is this rich people problem?
I'm kidding, I'm joking.
(laughs)
- It's entrepreneurial problems. (laughs)
No, I completely-
- I mean, this is why we became
fucking entrepreneurs, right?
- Yeah.
- I've never fucking enjoyed
cleaning in my life.
- No.
- I never will enjoy cleaning.
And-
- You know what's the only, I
guess housework quote, unquote
that I really enjoy?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Doing the laundry.
- Okay, laundry is nice.
There's something about
laundry, it hits man.
- I really like it.
It's like, I just put some
music on, I'm outside-
- Oh, you still clean.
You still clean.
- Yeah, usually
it's a nice day and I'm
just hanging up my clothes,
and I'm just like, hey, you know what?
- No.
- Stress free.
- Bro-
- Sub-optimize.
- Listen, listen.
(laughing)
- No. No, no, no.
- This is why Sydney does the laundry.
- Oh my God.
- Thank you Sydney by the way.
- This is why I get a woman to do it.
(laughing)
I laugh sometimes, 'cause my mom's like,
"You're gonna need to learn how to do
"the laundry someday, someday."
And then Sydney come-
- Formigation family bond.
(laughing)
- And then Sydney comes along
and it's like, I love laundry.
Laundry is so relaxing.
- It is, it is.
- I'm like, you-
- I'll think of thing of
like your old school teacher
being like you're not
gonna carry a calculator
with you every day.
It's like (laughs), about that?
- I'm gonna say it dude,
when you have fresh sheets not
only is that sleep the best.
- Yeah.
- It's the best wank you'll have in like
a whole month dude,
(laughs)
in fresh sheets, dude.
- You're disgusting.
- Wait, you wank away.
- Why am I disgusting Meilyne.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait,
time out, time out.
- That was...
Sorry, you can (indistinct).
- Are you like wanking onto your sheets.
Are you like jizzing on to it?
- I'm outside on the fucking...
No I'm kidding.
Now, when you put them on, it's so fresh,
the room smells nice,
and it feels comfortable.
You're like, ah, time to wank.
(laughing)
- That was the biggest they
had us in the first half
I've ever had on this podcast.
'Cause I was gonna be like,
yeah I know exactly what you...
Wait, what the fuck.
What are you saying?
- Are you saying
you don't like that.
Come on, Garnt.
- I don't jerk off in my bed.
- Yeah, I don't jerk off in my bed,
so that's probably why.
- Okay, well if you have sex
in it as well, its also great.
- Yeah, that's not what you said though.
You said fucking (indistinct).
- If you would have said that,
then we would be like,
yes I agree Connor, but-
- Same thing, same thing.
The same climax in the bed, fresh sheets,
all the same thing, dude.
(laughs)
- No, I love fresh sheets.
I hate the process of
getting fresh sheets.
- Okay, like putting on bed sheets-
- Okay, you've seen my setup.
(laughs)
- Wait, what's your setup?
- Connor. (laughs)
- Okay wait. (laughs)
- Connor has like...
Okay, you look at Connor's gaming setup,
it's like perfect.
Everything is like optimized.
Then you see his bed,
and it's like, one of those Reddit reacts
to some of the worst fucking
gaming setups you've ever seen.
It's like a $2 bed set up.
- Yeah.
- You just have like a fucking towel
on your fucking mattress.
- No, no.
- So there's literally nothing
in my bedroom except a bed.
And there's like, literally nothing.
There's like this-
- Why not?
- I don't know, it's
for my fucking bedroom,
I just sleep in there
and do anything else,
that's worth it.
- Yeah, your bed frame is like broken,
isn't it?
- Yeah, it's broken
as well, yeah.
(Joey laughs)
'Cause I bought the cheapest one on Amazon
when I moved here.
- Right.
- Cause, moving is expensive,
right?
- Yeah.
- And it was so expensive that I was like,
fuck I gotta cut cost.
But I regret it because
I bought a $200 bed
and that was the mattress combined.
- Yeah.
- And this shit fucking awful.
All the Springs are
fucked, the beds broken.
- It's literally-
- You were talking so much about like,
yeah, why would you buy a $20 headset,
when you can just buy a $100 one
and you get your money's worth?
- Here's the thing, here's the thing,
I had that philosophy, but
again moving kind of like
distorts your price range.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because you're spending like...
I got to put down like a
fucking 4K deposit on this shit,
the flights are this much, I
had to pay shipping for my PC.
Like I was spending a lot of money.
I'm like, fuck!
I'm kinda losing a lot of money.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I've gotta start saving costs.
I can't buy a 10K bed frame.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- So I bought
the cheapest one on Amazon,
which I regretted within about two weeks.
(Joey laughs)
Actually no, immediately when I built it,
'cause building it was a
pain in the fucking ass.
'Cause I could tell
when I was building it,
I'm like, oh no, this isn't
even like budget plywood.
This is like the throw away
plywood that they would use-
- This is like the foamy plywood.
- It's the worst.
- I remember seeing the exact bed frame
you bought on Amazon, and it
was like two and a half stars.
And that's when I knew that-
- Listen.
(laughs)
- Mistakes were made.
- Yeah.
- I just wanted something
and I wanted it now, and
I've regretted it so much.
But anyway, what happened was,
the most ghetto thing that I have
is that I'm actually using a bed sheet
as like a mattress cover.
- Wait what?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- So what happened was, right-
- How do you stretch that sheet over it?
- Okay, actually with a lot
like the fucking power of Zeus,
(Joey laughs)
I'm like (groans).
I'm like pulling the Red Sea back together
when I'm trying to put these bed sheet.
It's a zip.
- Yeah.
- It goes all around
my mattress.
- Oh, you fucking zipped
it around your mattress.
- Oh yeah.
- You like put it in?
(laughing)
- Right, right.
- You just fucking like
condomed your mattress.
- What the fuck did you do?
- I'm like fucking Spartacus,
when he's kicking the guy.
I'm like doing that to my mattress
every time I wash it.
(groans)
- Wait,
you have to do that every
time you wash your mattress
as well, sorry, wash your bed sheet?
- So I wash my bed sheet
as well, yeah, yeah.
- So I have-
- So you have to fucking
strip this thing out and then wash it,
and then condom it back in.
- Because-
- I feel so sorry
for your bed sheet, man.
- Yeah.
- Its very stretch.
Okay, but also I do avoid
that annoying thing.
This is like the only plus in this.
I've gone to the many negatives.
The only plus is that, you know
that fucking annoying thing
when you're sleeping and
the bed sheet comes off
in the corner?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You can never get it back on
unless you actually get off the bed.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I fucking hate that, that sucks.
Never have that issue.
- Because the entire
thing is wrapped. (laughs)
- Yeah, its zipped up around it.
- No, no.
I can see like the benefits of it,
because the best bedsheets
are the ones that are like
super tight, they're firm.
- Firm, firm.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If I see wrinkles
on that sheet,
(sighs)
that's like instant-
- You know it's soft too
because sometimes you'll wake up
and on your body you have imprints.
- Oh, I hate that.
- Yeah.
- And then I'm just like,
what the fuck is that?
- Instant soft sheet right there.
- I do have a backup bed sheet,
which is actually like
proper, but I refuse to use it
unless I'm desperate
because I love this one,
and I like even putting it back on.
- You love fucking turning
your mattress into a beanbag.
- So here's how I ended up
with bed sheet as my duvet
and it goes all around my mattress.
I fully put it all around
my mattress and zip it up
all around.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So when I moved here, I went to Nitori,
which is kinda like Japanese Ikea,
which I think we mentioned before.
I go there, right.
So I buy the pillows, the pillow sheets.
I buy the duvet and I
go to the staff member,
and I ask him.
And like I'm making sure I've
got Google translate, man.
I'm like, duvet or like
whatever they're fucking called,
blanket, whatever?
I did not say fucking futon.
I did not say futon.
I'm showing him, I'm like this.
I even showed a picture.
I'm like, I want this.
- Like a matrix,
like a couple of matrix.
- This part.
Which one is this?
Then like broken Japanese
with Google translate.
It's like, oh, no problem fam.
I got you.
Points me to this, I buy it.
I get home, what do you think it is?
It's a fucking futon.
And he saw me buy the
futon, another futon,
it wasn't even in the
same section as well,
so that's where I was
confused when I got home,
so I'm like, wait, this
was in a different section.
Why don't we have two
different futon types?
What is this?
So I have two fucking futon covers.
So I have the bed sheet and then I have,
yeah, the mattress.
(Joey laughs)
So I got home and I needed to sleep.
So I'm like, well, fuck it.
It's going in one way or another.
It's going over my bed.
I think Garnt helped me
the first time get it on.
This was a two-person-
- It was a two-person job.
- Like how the fucking do
you get that on yourself?
- So, the stuff we got...
Okay.
- I thought-
- Do you like cold, Garnt every time?
(laughing)
- You Just assumed that
you've got a duvet now?
- I've mastered the
technique of doing it, right.
(Joey laughs)
Okay, this is what I do.
To get it off it's easy.
'Cause it's like you're letting-
- It wants to get off.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's like letting a pig out of clothes.
That sheet wants to come up.
- Yeah.
- Get it back on, right?
Okay, first of all, this is the setup.
I flip my mattress to the side.
So it's upright.
And then I fucking pull over half.
And I flip it upside down
the other end, pull it up.
And then this basically,
what happens is that
it's up to here, right?
So this is horizontal way, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I've got to basically force
this sheet together.
Grab it together and hold it.
And it hurts my hands 'cause it's tight.
I gotta like slowly pull a
little bit by little bit.
And if I let go, it all goes back.
So I have to keep grabbing
a little bit and zipping,
grabbing a little bit and zipping.
It's a pain in the
fucking ass and I hate it.
- Why don't you just get a fucking duvet?
- It's like putting on the
world's largest condom.
- No, no dude.
(indistinct) is the bed sheet.
- Just get a proper bed sheet.
- Yeah, just get a proper bed sheet.
- Because, you know what?
I love the firmness of it.
I love how tight it is around my bed-
- Just get a fucking bed sheet.
- At this point, you might as well
not even have a fucking bed sheet.
- Why, why?
I like it.
- No, no, no.
- There's a difference
between having no bed sheet
and having a firm bed sheet.
- I sweat like a motherfucker.
I need a bed sheet.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So then just buy
a fucking bed...
It's like a thousand yen.
- I don't know, I've kind
of gotten used to it now.
(laughing)
I kinda like it now though-
- Its not a struggle to him obviously
- This man literally made a Spreadsheet
trying to optimize cooking
and he can't even buy a fucking bed sheet.
- Well.
(roars) (laughing)
Because then I gotta optimize that.
That's another thing I would optimize.
I'm sick of it man.
Well, to be fair,
that whole organization with the Uber Eats
was just to justify to
myself why I can have
pad thai three times a week.
- Right, right.
- To be honest. (chuckles)
- I like the final result of cooking
and cleaning fucking bedsheets.
But like having to change your duvet,
do you find it annoying?
It's like fiddliest fucking thing ever
to like take the duvet off
and like putting it back on,
and having to make sure every corner
is perfectly situated on every-
- If you have a zipped up one
every corner will be.
- No, no, no.
- It doesn't have a choice.
- Not the bed sheet, the
actual fucking blanket part.
- Oh, that's easy, 'cause
the ones in Japan, big brain.
They come with the holes at the end,
so you can just flip it up inside, out,
grab the thing, and then.
- Yeah, that's what I always do.
- Did you know you could do that?
- Yeah.
- No.
What?
- That's what I've done
ever since I was little
- So you turn it inside out.
- Yeah, I do that.
- And then you, like a little
ghost, you put it over you-
(indistinct) with both hands.
- Yeah, I do that.
- And you grab the ends of the futon,
and then you just like flip it over,
and then shake it down.
- Yeah then shake it down.
- And then release.
- But like for me, I don't know if-
- Isn't that that what hotels do?
Yeah, 'cause they gotta speedrun it,
'cause they're doing like a hundred rooms.
- I don't know if my like...
'Cause I think I have
like my fucking nightmare
where my duvet is not the
same size as my blanket.
It's slightly bigger.
(Joey laughs)
So I always have like left-
- I hate that, I hate that.
- So you have like a little bit of fabric
left over.
- Oh my God,
It triggers me so much, man.
- I hate the ones like...
Our old fucking duvet
it was the perfect size.
But the problem was is that it would...
The duvet inside would move around.
- I hate that.
- Yeah.
- So like one end of the
duvet would just have like,
just fucking scrunched up
so that you try and pull
it over, it's just sheet.
And I'm just like fuck,
where the fucking duvet go?
- This why I think you are most likely
to have a mental breakdown when
you're doing your bedsheets,
or putting your duvet on.
I don't know what it is-
- That's why I fucking hate it, man.
That's why I fucking hate it.
- I don't know what it is
about putting sheets on,
but what if it just doesn't work?
You're like, fuck it.
I just wanna cry and just
be like, why won't it work?
Why won't it work?
Why is my day going bad.
- I used to work in a hotel lodges
in like ski fields and stuff,
and I had to do that
shit every fucking day.
- Really?
- Yeah.
So I basically-
- Do you shovel shit out of the drains
and then you gotta go do that?
- Yeah.
- I was basically-
- That sounds like
my nightmare.
- Yeah, so at first
I fucking hated it.
I was like, oh-
- And then he came to adopt the sheet.
- There's 30 rooms in this hotel,
that doesn't seem too bad.
Five rooms in and you're like,
fuck man, I wanna go home.
Just fucking around with the duvet.
It's just like not going in.
I have 25 rooms left to do this.
- I would actually have a mental breakdown
if I just do like five
sheets in like one hour.
I would actually be like,
no, I don't think life
is for (indistinct).
- Yeah.
- I'm like, I'm not getting
paid enough for this shit.
- I would actually work in-
- I'd rather shovel shit.
- Yeah, I'd rather shovel shit
and like fucking get shouted at McDonald's
than do five duvets in a row, man.
- So now I'm just used to it
'cause I've lived through
that fucking Vietnam war.
- What didn't you do at this job, Joey?
Jesus Christ.
(Joey scoffs)
- I didn't work in the kitchen,
that's for sure. (laughs)
- Yeah, because there's
something fucking special
about hotel duvets.
Getting in like a hotel bed
and just feeling like you're
in a fucking straight jacket,
I don't know, man.
I fucking love that feeling.
- I don't like it when hotels do that,
when they fucking-
- Yeah, because you get
in the bed and you're like, what is this,
the world's fucking strongest
man for weight pulling?
- You just have to fucking
like shimmy yourself into it.
- Yeah.
- I love that feeling.
You feel like fucking safe.
You feel covered.
- No, I feel like I'm
in a straight jacket.
- This is my safe zone right now
and no one can fucking touch me.
I feel like a moth.
I feel like a fucking caterpillar
who is like about to fucking-
- No! (laughs)
- Okay, what about...
I hate it when they tuck
half the fucking duvet
under the front of the bed.
So you're getting in and
it's like you're trying
to fucking tow a car when
you're pulling this sheet out.
You're like this on the bed.
(groans)
- I just shimmy myself
in and I'm just like, ah.
I feel like I'm back in
my mom's room right now.
Nothing can harm me.
- I can't even shimmy myself in.
It's like I'm trying to get
into pants five sizes too small.
It's just like, fuck I gotta get in.
- I feel bad as well when they
put like a cloth on the bed,
I don't know, like that sheet they put
on the front of the bed.
I'm like, get rid of that.
Get that fucking out of here.
- Oh the thing at like the end?
- It's like a linen thing or something.
I don't know what it is.
- You know what that's for?
- What is that for?
- It's for...
Apparently it's an American thing.
Apparently it's so that you
can wear shoes on the bed.
(gasping)
- Oh!
- I'm about to leave right now.
- So, you probably seen
it before in hotels
where there's just like this one weird
like fucking tablecloth size-
- Yeah I hate that thing.
- [Connor] At the end of the bed, right?
- That's for shoes?
- That's the shoes.
- But they do that in Japanese hotels
where you have to take your
shoes off at the front.
- Yeah, that's what I don't understand.
- Why?
(laughs)
- Okay, okay.
- I understand
in American hotels-
- As the only white person here-
- No, no, no.
(Joey laughs)
Don't put this on me.
- I need your opinion.
- I was raised correctly.
(Joey laughs)
- Shoes on sofas and beds.
- No, it-
- Does that trigger you,
as it should?
- Yes, yes. Of course.
My parents would hit me if I did that.
You kidding me?
- I've never understood.
I always thought, you
know when you'd watch
"The Simpsons" or like
American TV shows or whatever,
how they would take their
shoes off before going to bed.
They would like keep their
shoes on the side of the bed,
and then when they wake up
the first thing they would do
is put shoes on.
I just thought that was like parody.
I didn't actually think
Americans did that.
- I mean, it's not just America,
it's most of the fucking West.
As an Asian, I'm just like,
why did the West just normalize
war cries?
- I'm like, why your like
dirty fucking gross ass
shoes on the carpet?
That shit's gross.
(laughs)
- That's what blows my mind.
I'm like, you are literally dragging
daily shit into your carpet
by bringing your shoes in.
It drives me insane.
- And then people complain being like,
oh man, I hate carpet
because it's so dirty.
I'm like, well, yeah cause
you're put your own shoes.
- Whenever I would go to a friend's house
and they would be like...
And I go to his house
and he would be like,
"It's okay, you can keep your shoes on."
I'm like, motherfucker, tell
me to take my shoes off.
I want to take my shoes off, man.
- I would actually (indistinct).
I'm not a fucking animal.
I'm not gonna bring dirt
into the house, all right?
- I don't know what it is,
but when I'm shitting with
shoes on in somebody's house,
it feel so weird.
(Joey laughs)
I feel like I'm in a public restroom.
I don't wanna shit with my shoes on.
I wanna be comfortable, man.
Yeah, this shit drives me insane.
And there's people...
There'll be people call me and be like,
"I wear my shoes in bed."
Stop.
- Stop.
- For your own sake,
please stop.
- It's gross.
- Please.
If you wanna go against the
Geneva Conventions, just do it.
Do it in your own fucking-
(Joey laughs)
- It goes against basic human rights.
- Yeah, I know right.
(laughing)
- To wear shoes in bed.
- I love all our fans except for the ones
that wear shoes to their bed.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
(laughing)
- All my homies hate people
who wear shoes in bed.
- My God.
I went to fucking...
Jesus, my editor Evan,
I went to his house and
that was disgusting.
(Joey laughing)
He had like a five inch thick carpet.
- [Joey] Right?
- I don't know what color this
carpet was supposed to be,
but it definitely wasn't
the color that it came as.
This shit was vile, dude.
Evan, fix that fucking carpet man.
And they all will wore like
the dirtiest shoes inside,
and I was like, Evan, I can't, I can't.
- Right, I'm like have you
not heard of house slippers?
- I know right?
- Yeah.
- If you have to wear something,
just wear slippers.
- Why?
What's wrong with bare feet, man or socks.
- Yeah, but even if,
dude slippers, it's fine,
it's clean.
- Okay.
(whooshing)
- This video is sponsored
by Skillshare.
- No matter what 2021 brings,
you can spend it creating
something meaningful
with SkillShare's online classes,
because time is what we make of it.
- Damn, that's deep.
- [Connor] SkillShare is an
online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
So much to explore,
real projects to create,
and the support of fellow creatives.
Skillshare empowers you to
accomplish really growth, Garnt.
- Listen, I don't upload onto
Instagram and do selfies,
and stuff like that often.
But when I do, I want myself
and whatever I'm taking-
- Naturally.
- To look clean, right?
You want it to look good?
- Exactly, exactly.
- So I use iPhone Photography:
How to Shoot and Edit
Conceptual photos on Your Phone,
taught by Adobe creative
resident, Amelie Satzger.
- Holy shit, holy fuck man.
- And I watched that
and I was like, hey, you know what,
you can take good photos with your iPhone.
That's exactly what I do.
- I would definitely use that,
because I post on Instagram
at least once every-
- Who's carrying around
a DSLR at all times.
- Exactly.
- You carry your phone
around though.
- Yeah.
- That's true.
- For the like the one
post in every two years,
I post on Instagram it'll
be fucking perfect for.
- Yeah, you need it more than anybody.
- [Connor] With SkillShare,
you can find inspiration in the moment,
and learn how to express your creativity.
- Bring color, beauty,
and fun to your year-
- All caps.
(laughing)
- Add vivid details and
craft complex wonders.
- [Joey] Skillshare is
also incredibly affordable,
especially when compared
to pricey in-person classes
and workshops, and annual subscription
is less than 10$, gentlemen.
- I mean they're
practically giving it away.
- Explore your creativity
at skillshare.com/trashtaste
and get a free trial
of premium membership.
- That's skillshare.com/trashtaste,
link's down in the description below.
Thanks you for sponsoring the episode,
back to the show.
(whooshing)
- Going back to the topic
of beds and everything.
Opinions on pajamas.
Do any of you guys wear pajamas?
- I sleep naked.
- Specifically like pajamas.
- Yeah, just pajamas.
- No, for me it's just like underwear
and some random T-shirt.
- All right, good.
I don't understand pajamas at all.
And some people-
- Do you wear a T-shirt to bed?
I don't wanna wear...
Why would you wear a T-shirt To bed?
- Unless it's like fucking stinking hot,
like in the summer, I'll wear no shirt.
But most of the time
I have to wear a shirt.
- Max comfort
is the least amount of clothes
you could wear, basically.
And you basically only wear boxers
so you're fucking dangly
bits don't go everywhere.
That's pretty much
the only reason though.
- I like the freedom though.
Let them loose.
(laughs)
I'm sleeping, I wanna be comfy.
- No like, I don't know.
I like wearing a T-shirt
because sometimes in the morning
the weather can completely change.
Especially nowadays in the winter,
I'm a little bit too cold if I don't wear,
at least a T-shirt,
even with the heater on.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, I don't know.
- What about when you stay
like a friend's house?
Do you wear a T-shirt when you sleep?
'Cause I'm just like
immediately, I'm like,
right I'm stripping.
I'm getting-
- It depends how close I am
to that friend, really?
- It doesn't matter who they are, right?
If I'm staying in your house, I'm sorry.
I'll sleep with boxers on, I'll humor you.
(laughs)
I won't get my junk everywhere.
I'll sleep with boxers on.
- So like you can just not wear a shirt.
- I can't sleep with the T-shirt on.
- Why?
- I don't know, I feel
like I'm outside still?
When I take the T-shirt off,
in my head it signifies,
okay we're going to bed
or I'm going in the bath.
- Are you the type of person who like
when doing a serious heavy shit,
you have to like take your shirt off
- No, but.
(Joey laughs)
- Wait, wait.
- No, I know people like that.
- Go back.
- You don't know people like that?
- No.
- I do, I do.
(laughs)
- I had a few friends
where like if the pain
was really fucking, it
was such a powerful shit.
They'd be to like fully get
out like a 100% of their power,
they would to take my shirt off.
- You're trolling me.
- No, no, no, no.
You know right?
You know people like that.
They're just like, "Fuck man,
I need to take my shirt off
"to get serious with this shit."
- What the fuck is this? (laughs)
- How did you not know this?
- This is satire.
- No, its so serious.
- Where is the hidden camera?
No fucking way is this true right now.
- I'm serious, I'm serious.
- What, do you think like
fucking Goku would've wait
to cheer us or something?
Its just like, hold on.
Let me use a 100% of my
power to push this shit out.
- Yeah.
Because you're sweating so hard,
you're just like, I need
to take my shirt off.
- Also when you're like hung over-
- (indistinct) I can't.
(laughing)
- When you're hung over,
the shits are terrible,
right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So you're like, fuck, I just woke up.
I'm naked, so fuck it,
I'll do it when I'm naked
'cause it's just better.
- Not gonna lie,
I've had moments where the
shit's been so powerful
and stressful where I'm just like,
I have to take my shirt off.
(laughing)
- And I don't know if it's like-
- I don't do that, but
I know people who do.
- Yeah, I don't know if it's
like placebo, but it works.
(laughs)
He's fucking crying.
- I'm fucking imagining like
fucking Tyler (indistinct)
on this shit.
(screaming)
Just like.
(groans)
(laughs)
- The only time when I'm like-
- I can't believe
this is real.
- If I'm ever vomiting,
I wanna be naked.
- What?
- Because I don't wanna
get that shit anywhere
or smell my clothes.
So I'm like, I'll just get naked
and I'll hug this toilet
bowl until I'm done.
- But if your hugging
it, then there's no way
you're gonna fucking blah
onto your shirt, right?
- I just don't want in
my clothes at all, man.
- Right.
- I'm like, I don't know.
And also, it feels better.
I don't know why.
I need to get like...
(Joey laughs)
This is restrictive, I'm
getting stuffy in these.
I just wanna vomit. (laughing)
(roaring)
I don't know, when i was to have like-
- How did you vomit without your clothes?
(laughing)
'Cause every time I've seen
you vomit you have clothes on.
- Oh yeah, true.
I was (indistinct) drunk.
(laughing)
But, when I'm like...
If you're really sick, like
when I had food poisoning
back in like whenever,
when they thought I had the rona,
I was vomiting and I had to be naked.
'cause I was like, otherwise,
I felt like it'd get off my clothes.
And I'm like, that's gross.
It's so fucked.
- Little did you know
that during the chess tournament,
every time you went to take a shit,
he just fucking rip off his suit.
- That was awful when I was
taking shit with the suit on.
I'm like, please, please
don't get it on the suit.
- That's the worst timing to take a shit.
Is when your in a full suit.
(laughs)
You're like, ah.
- I'd like tuck it in,
belt it up.
- It's like, ah.
It's gross.
- 'Cause for me wearing a T-shirt in bed
is just like, sometimes,
especially in the winter
you wake up and it's like
a cold fucking morning.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
- And like how do you escape
your duvet at that point?
- It's like, I don't know, being branded.
You're like just fucking do it.
Just do it.
- No.
For me it's just like
gravity has increased tenfold
in this bed.
(Garnt laughs)
I'm like experiencing 10
G's in this bed right now.
It's like, I actually can't get out.
- It literally takes me like an hour
to get out of bed in this case.
- I have like the fucking
"Call of Duty" text
popping up on my screen,
mission, get to the shower.
Like that's what it's like for me.
- I have to do like one
limb at a time to be like,
all right, let me just
get my right arm out
and once that's like room temperature
then I'll get my right leg out.
It's like, all right, now I can go.
- I used to have like a heated thing
that you could put under your bed.
But that just made me
lazier, so I got rid of it.
- (chuckles) What do you mean?
- 'Cause I never wanted to leave the bed.
- Like a heated bed.
- Like a heated thing under the mattress
so that it was always warm.
But then I was like, this
is also a fire hazard
and yeah, I just don't...
I can not get out of bed with this thing.
- Yeah that's true.
- I mean, okay, have we
talked about a kotatsu before?
- I don't remember.
- I don't think we have.
Explain them to the audience Garnt.
- So they watch anime, you watch anime,
you know what a kotatsu is.
(Joey laughs)
If you don't know what a kotatsu is,
it's basically like a heated coffee table
where it's like a little coffee table
that has blankets around it
and you put your legs in it
and you put them under,
and it's all nice and cozy, and warm.
And it is amazing.
- I don't know about amazing.
- I think it's fucking amazing.
- There's a few logistical issues
that crop up with kotatsu.
Well, how many legs can fit under there?
- Depends on how big the table is?
- It's normally not that big.
You can comfortably probably
fit two people's legs.
- No.
- Are you comparing this to my kotatsu
which is fucking tiny?
- No, no, no, like a normal kotatsu.
'Cause I wanna stretch my legs fully out
underneath that thing.
You can only really fit
like two before you start
touch people's legs.
I don't wanna touch Joey's legs,
their disgusting.
- Why not?
(laughs)
- Disgusting.
- All my homies touch legs.
(laughs)
- I don't wanna play footsie
with Joey under the table
when I'm playing Uno. (laughs)
- I want to.
- Fucking stop.
- I wanna twiddle toes while I call Uno.
- What if you don't know them super...
Oh you pretty do know the (indistinct).
- Yeah, exactly.
- If you sharing a kotatsu.
- I'm not sharing a kotatsu
with a fucking stranger.
- Why not?
- Yeah.
- That's weird.
- That should be in a restaurant.
(laughs)
- It's nice, but then also
I find that it's like...
I know you can turn it up and down,
but it's either like I
would rather the room be hot
than my legs be hot.
Does that make sense?
- No, I would not rather that.
- No? No?
- Okay, I literally had
this problem recently
which is why I get reminded why I really
don't fucking like winter, right?
So unlike these boys,
I fucking hate the cold
and I hate winter.
- I love the cold.
- And the reason
I hate it is because,
you're in a cold room
and you wanna get comfortable,
so what'd you do, you
put it on the heater,
but I hate the feeling of a stuffy room.
- [Joey] Right.
- Like this room's getting bit-
- Have you considered-
- You're from a
stuffy country though.
- Have you considered wearing
another item of clothing?
(Joey laughs)
Perhaps a jumper or a hoodie?
- No, no, no.
Because there's a problem
because if you wear
a fucking jumper or something
and the room is cold,
then your fucking hands are cold.
And like I'm just trying
to work.
- It is not that cold.
- No, it can get that
cold sometimes in winter.
- Does the blood circulate
to your fingers enough or?
- My fucking feet...
Before we turned on this heater,
my fucking feet were ice cold, man.
I am not joking.
- It's really not that cold.
- I get cold limbs.
- Are you a fucking lizard
with your body.
What the fuck.
(laughs)
- No, my body was just
not built for the cold
and there's nothing more
uncomfortable for me-
- Built different in the opposite.
- Than just a stuffy room.
'Cause sometimes I'm like,
maybe I'm getting ill.
And then I realize I go outside
and it's because the room's so stuffy
that I haven't realized how
uncomfortable I'm feeling-
- But that's why I very
rarely turn on the heater,
unless it's like a seriously cold.
Because for me it's like, if I'm cold,
I'll just wear another layer of clothing.
And then A, the room isn't
stuffy and B, I'm warm.
- But also it's really easy
to make a room not stuffy.
You just open a window for like one minute
after you've heated the up.
It won't be cold
after one minute.
- Yeah, but then after
you open the window,
then it gets cold again.
- And then like one minute-
- And then
the cycle continues-
- Not in one minute.
- There is never a perfect temperature
that I'm like happy with when it's winter.
Because if I need to like
artificially warm it up,
then either it's gonna be too stuffy
or I'm gonna be too cold.
There is no between.
- But there's something so nice
about being in a warm room,
knowing it's freezing outside.
- Yeah, I agree.
- There's something
that's so magical about that.
- It's like going to bed
in a thunderstorm, right?
There's something comforting about it.
- Yeah.
- I don't if you guys relate to that.
(laughing)
- I just gave you like
the thousand yard stare.
You were like, "Yeah, you guys
know what I'm talking about."
- No, I like it, I like it.
I know what you mean.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just like white noise outside
(indistinct)
- Yeah.
There's something comforting about outside
is fucked right now, but I'm
safe inside dry and warm.
- Some of the best sleeps I've had
I've been like camping on the floor,
but because it's so
fucking freezing outside
and you're in your
little like worm cocoon,
it's so nice.
- Yeah, I agree, I agree.
- It's, oh yeah.
- Oh fuck.
- I just like being
comfortable existing, I guess.
(laughs)
I don't want to do anything
to make my existence more comfortable.
I just like being in
a room and being like,
okay, I can do whatever I want.
- I think you just spoke
on behalf of all humanity.
(laughs)
I just want a comfortable existence-
- I just wanna be-
- He just wants to wear a
fucking turtleneck in his room
and be a happy boy.
(Joey laughing)
- Honestly, what's wrong with that?
I don't wanna put on a heater-
- Okay, to be honest,
the only reason why I...
Okay, two reasons why I
don't wear turtlenecks, A-
- You look like an asshole.
- I look like a dick.
B, my neck-
- Yo, Steve Hanjobs
here though, come on.
- No, no,
you can make it work.
I can't make it work.
I look like a fucking
weirdo with a turtleneck.
But B, my neck for some reason,
I don't know what it is,
it exerts so much fucking heat that...
(laughing)
Like legit.
That's the reason why I
can't wear a scarf, either.
Because when I wear a scarf,
my neck gets so fucking sweaty.
- Bro, I fucking love wearing scarfs.
- I know, I-
- Scarfs are great.
- I love wearing scarves too,
but only if it's like really,
like I'm talking like,
- 10, -20 degrees.
- Literally the reason why I
started wearing turtle necks,
had nothing to do with like me thinking,
turtleneck looks nice.
I just remember the first
time I put on a turtleneck,
I'm like, oh, this is like
permanently wearing a scarf
that I'd never have to take off.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- This is like perfect for me.
- Exactly.
- 'Cause I fucking love
the feeling of wearing scarfs.
- Exactly, but it doesn't
matter how cold it is for me,
I don't know why I get
so sweaty around my neck.
- Who needs renewable energy
when we can just use Joey
fucking neck to power the planet?
- You can just all hurdle
around my neck like this
and just warm your hands up on my neck.
I don't know what it is.
My neck is always so fucking hot.
Which sucks, because
people have always told me,
"Oh yeah, you look
really good in a scarf."
And I'm like, yeah, I like wearing scarfs
that I like the feeling of it.
But I can only wear for maybe like-
- Wait, you say that you're fine
but you're not really fine.
- Yeah, exactly. (chuckles)
It's like, I like wearing a scarf
and I think I look good in a scarf,
but the problem is I can't wear a scarf
for more than two minutes.
'Cause then I'm like,
fuck this, it's so hot.
I can't.
- Overheating, overloading.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Kinda on topic...
Okay, go on Garnt.
- Yeah, going back to why I like kotatsus
is that kotatsus is like, I
can feel warm in a kotatsu
and not feel stuffy.
So it's like one of the few
spaces where I'm just like,
if I'm getting hot, I can
just roll on the kotatsu and-
- But that's the problem
I have with kotatsu,
is this exact same problem
I have with beds in winter?
Is that the moment I enter the kotatsu
the G's jerk up like 10
G's and I can't leave it.
- Yeah, yeah, I feel the same way.
- Also how are we look
sitting on the floor?
Sitting on the floor isn't
that comfortable for me.
- [Joey] Right.
- And kotatsu you normally
have to sit on the floor.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I need some like back support, man.
- But there's those chairs.
- There's the back support.
(indistinct)
- Yeah, those are pretty good.
But, most of the time they don't
really have those, do they?
It's just kinda like, you just sit,
and you've gotta put your hands back
if you wanna lean back a little bit.
- You can lean back on the couch.
- Yeah, if there's a
couch there, it's nice
but (indistinct) people don't have that.
I mean, (indistinct), right?
- Right.
- But, I'm being nitpicky.
- You should just bring your
own fucking foldable chair.
It's like if you have kotatsu, I'm coming.
- I'm like that guy
with the camping chair,
like flips it out with hand.
I'm like, I'm ready for the kotatsu.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- I'm ready to be comfortable.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, honestly kotatsu...
I remember the first time
I tried out a kotatsu
here in Japan and it was like
instant life-changing moment.
- What do you mean?
(Joey laughs)
It's just a warm table.
What are you here like,
(Joey laughs)
how is it life-changing?
- Come on, come on,
come on, come on.
- Fuck off!
- Like you have some of those moments
where you're just like,
how did I go my entire life without this?
Like okay, heat-
- It is pretty fucking likable.
- Heated toilet seats.
The first time I went to Japan
and tried a heated toilet
seat, I'm just like,
how is the rest of the
first world fucking...
Other first world countries
haven't caught on to this.
- Yeah, I won't lie,
I think I have actually
ruined toilets myself.
'Cause whenever I go to a toilet now
that doesn't have a
bidet, I legit feel like
I'm bored.
- I have a panic attack.
(laughs)
- I legit feel like, how am I
supposed to wash my ass clean?
Wipe it, are you kidding me?
I'm not an animal.
I don't touch that area.
If I ever move back to the UK, no joke,
I'm 100% like-
- Invest in a bidet.
- Even if the suitcase
is empty, dude, I'm making room
for the premium $1,000 bidet,
because I'm using that shit daily.
I wanna shit like a king.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And like I remember Prosey D,
I was talking to him, as well one time.
He was like, dude when
he came back from Japan
the one thing he brought was a bidet.
- Really?
- 'Cause he was like,
I insist.
- I feel him
- He has taste, man, he has taste.
- He was arguing like, I
insist that I shit like a king.
And I'm like, honestly,
(Joey laughs)
I completely understand it.
'Cause once you get used to a bidet
and you get the heated seat,
you get a little pressure washer
you can have it set to
like boom, boom, boom,
that go back and forth on your
ass cheeks, it's nice dude.
My ass feels permanently clean.
Why wouldn't I wanna shower
for my ass every time shit?
Are you kidding me?
Sometimes I don't even shit, but I do it
'cause I'm like, why not clean my ass.
Why not?
(Joey laughs)
I got time.
- I got some time.
- I got time.
- I wanna make my ass
feel refreshed.
'Cause sometimes right, man,
you have those days where
like it's a hot day.
you get like swamp ass,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Where you're ass
just gets kinda sweaty.
It's not even bad, but
just a little bit, right?
You're like, why not just clean it.
- You're butt cheeks get
a little (indistinct).
- Why not clean my cheeks?
- Okay, I completely missed on this.
So you're not talking about
it's heated seat.
- The heated seat
is also amazing.
- But you're talking bidet?
- Yeah, the bidet and...
But the heated seat is part
of the bidet package, right?
Even the cheapest ones have that.
- Okay, I don't use the
ass washing function
of the bidet at all.
- Why not?
- It just doesn't feel clean.
I don't know.
- It's clean.
- I don't know.
- It's the cleanest thing
in the toilet.
- It does not and like I-
- You are kidding me.
This is like going to
space and being like,
yeah, I never look out the window.
Why would I ?
(Joey laughs)
Why would I look at the window?
- So you bidet your ass, right?
You got the water shooting up your ass
and then you stop it, and then
you just got wet ass cheeks.
- So you get some of the toilet paper
and you just dry it a little bit.
- Yeah, you dry it off.
- Yeah, because like you
need the toilet paper,
but it doesn't feel
clean without that wipe.
- That's why you have to wipe.
- Some of them have dryers
and those are pretty good.
- No, no, no.
- Have you tried?
Have you tried Garnt?
- I have you tried.
- Fuck off, you haven't tried.
- I have tried.
- No, no, no.
Okay, because there is a
difference between wiping to dry...
Why are we talking
about this (indistinct)?
There's a different in
wiping to dry your ass
and wiping to get the shit out.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're very different
types of wipes, right?
- One is like a deep wipe
and the other is like a shower wipe.
- One is just-
- One is an excavation,
the other is a pat down.
- Look, toilet papers were not
designed to wipe wet asses.
- No, because your ass isn't
the fucking Amazon River, dude.
It's a little moist.
You just wipe that shit dry.
- What I hate is When you
have a wet ass after a bidet,
you go to wipe it and the toilet paper
just fucking disintegrates on your hand.
- Bro are you using one ply?
- How much water
are you fucking using?
- Okay, how much water can your asshole
in vertical position contain?
(laughs) (claps)
- It doesn't matter.
- And second of all-
- Its fucking toilet paper.
- What ply are you using Garnt?
What ply are you using?
One ply, fucking sandpaper?
What are you using to absorb this?
- You gotta use the double though,
at least
- Bro, double minimum.
Come on.
- Toilet paper-
- What ply are you using Garnt?
Answer real quick.
- What's a ply?
- (chuckles) It's how many
sheets of paper is used in it.
- Bro, okay.
- Are you using one square
and be like shit I'm allowed.
- It doesn't fucking matter, man.
Anyone who lives in Asia-
- No, no, it does matter.
- Anyone who lives in Asia
knows that toilet paper here
is weak as fuck.
It is flacid.
- That sounds broke.
That sounds broke as fuck.
You sound broke right now Garnt.
I can't believe how much
of a peasant joke this is.
- 'Cause I thought it
was just a Thai thing
where toilet paper was just
like fucking flacid, no.
I moved to Japan and toilet paper here
is like fucking weak as fuck.
- No, you can't buy the good shit.
- Yeah, you get the double ply shit
and then you do maybe like
one wrap around your hand.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's more than enough to
absorb any amount of liquid
that's down three.
- Yeah, you would pile on
three little sheets.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's a nice
thickness to it, right?
They're two-ply (indistinct).
- At least that thick, and
then just get under there
it won't rip.
- Good.
- And your ass is clean and it's dry.
- I cannot believe you would come here...
'Cause honestly, bidet is
in the top three things
about Japan, if I'm
gonna be honest with you.
- Heated toilet seats.
Bidet's okay.
- The whole shitting
experience is top three.
- The whole toilet experience.
- It's like a top three
Japanese thing for me, man.
Like it's just great.
- Okay, another thing-
- I look forward to shitting.
- Another thing about bidets as well,
it shoots up right up your asshole, right?
- That's exactly what I want.
- And then you just feel like
you're fucking shitting
out water and so like-
- How gaped is your asshole?
- Do you like goatse?
- Yeah, he's like this.
(laughs)
He's like. (grunts)
Like just sit down on it, man.
(claps)
- That's just fucking water
stuck in your asshole, man.
- A bidet-
- No. (laughs)
- Are you like giving yourself
a prostate massage on a bidet.
- No.
- It's just not-
- Do you got water stuck in your anus?
- No.
- How do you do that?
What is your asshole like?
- Unless I'm fucking like.
(laughing)
- Are you putting your
asshole over the bidet thing.
Are you putting it in?
- With the hose.
- Yeah, are you putting the hose in?
What are you doing?
- No, the stream of water
is fucking strong enough-
- Put that down, put it down.
(laughing)
You probably set it to
like fucking pressure hose.
- Well, that's how-
- He's got it to like
public fountain display.
- No, no, no.
- Because if its not strong,
then it's just a fucking
trickle on your ass,
and that's no cleaning up shit.
- That is called medium.
- You need the fucking pressure
to fucking clean that shit off your ass.
But if it has enough pressure
to clean the shit off your ass,
then you're getting water
stuck in your asshole.
There's no in between.
- No, you're not.
No you're not.
- My bidet is on the fucking
max pressure and it's perfect,
because you can feel
the shit coming off and,
I mean, I don't know about you,
but my asshole is normal.
- Fucking ironclad asshole
right here man.
- Yeah, just clench it a bit
and you're all right.
- I clench up a little bit.
- 'Cause if you clench then your not
fucking cleaning it properly.
- Yes you are.
- When you're shitting, what do you mean?
(laughing)
Wait, you're not cleaning
it properly when you clench?
Of course you are.
- Yeah.
- What do you mean like clench?
Wait you clench when you
fucking bidet that shit?
- A little bit.
- Pucker up your asshole.
- Yeah, pucker up a little bit.
(laughing)
(claps)
- Garnt is like relax my anus.
Allow the water to flow in.
What are you doing?
- You're giving yourself
a fucking bidet anima.
(laughing)
- That's what it feels like.
It obviously feels like I'm
taking a fucking bidet anima
every time.
- You're doing this
totally wrong Garnt.
(laughs)
- Oh my God.
- Wait, because like I
don't clench when I shit.
- What do you mean?
You're just like, I let
gravity do its work. (laughs)
- What is this, a fun slip
and slide you're asshole?
How is the shit coming out?
- How lubed up is your asshole?
- What do you mean by clench?
You just mean push?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, punch.
It's the same thing, normally.
- No, okay, that doesn't
how with the bidet is.
Still goes up the fucking asshole
even if you push that shit out, man.
- We need an anatomy of
your asshole in display.
Can we get an X-ray of your asshole
so we can see what's going on.
- Can we get like a bidet cam
just to see how fucking
loose your asshole is
when it gets bidet. (laughs)
- I just don't like the
feeling of water on my ass
and I don't know, it just-
- So wait, what about in the shower?
- Yeah, what do you
cleaning your ass with?
- No.
Okay, so you know when-
- Do you clean your ass Garnt?
- Yeah, I clean my fucking ass.
- How do you clean your ass?
- You talked about the sweaty feeling
in your asshole.
- Swamp ass.
- Yeah, swamp ass.
If I get swamp ass, I just
take a fucking shower, man.
I don't even bidet that shit.
- A whole shower,
- Yeah I fuck-.
- That's so unnecessary.
- I can take three showers a day
if I need to.
- Garnt takes one shit
and goes home, he's like
fuck gotta shower now, man.
- Honestly, sometimes
if I wanna feel clean
after a shit I just take
a fucking shower, man.
Quick five minute.
- What are you doing in this toilet?
Garnt is that one dude when
you leave some public restrooms
it's like a fucking war zone.
- Yeah.
- That must be Garnt.
- No, no, no.
- The shit everywhere,
shit on the wall.
(Joey laughs)
It's like, that is Garnt.
It's Garnt going in the rest room-
- It's like shit in places
you didn't think shit would end up.
- It's the fucking opposite, man.
My shit-
- Why would I use a bidet
when it can't reach the wall. (laughs)
- My shits are like the cleanest shits.
- Fuck off!
- They are.
- There's no such thing as a clean shit.
- Okay, have you never
had the perfect shit.
- The no wipes, yeah.
- Yeah, the perfect
shit, which is just like
you just shit out a log and
it's like one solid clean log.
And then you look at it
and it's like, no wipe,
you look at it and you're just like,
man, that's a fucking
piece of art right there.
- In my family, we call that the swish,
because it doesn't touch the sides.
(laughing)
- I hope no one's eating
during this episode.
(laughing)
- Yo, I just did a
swisher over there, man.
- You don't need a fucking bidet
after you did that fucking swish, man.
- I mean, I still like it though.
I still do it anyway
because it feels good.
- To me, that is like the
equivalent of coming to Japan
and just being like, yeah man,
I just ate only KFC and Burger King.
It's like, you've wasted
the true potential of Japan.
Like what have you done?
It is on pearl honestly with
food talking about Japan.
Like food is amazing and
the shitting experience
is also God like.
(Joey laughs)
I actually look forward to taking a shit.
- Yeah.
- I can't wait
to crack open the bidet
and just feel amazing.
(laughing)
- Crack open the bidet.
- Crack open the.
- Crack open the bidet with the boys.
- Crack open the bidet and
just have a great fucking time.
- Yeah.
- (laughs) You shit for pleasure.
- Honestly, I do.
- Yeah.
- Honestly, I used to shit
'cause it was a bodily function.
now I look forward to my
shits 'cause it's Japan.
And they've figured out
how to make shitting
an enjoyable experiences.
- I look forward to
shitting for other reasons.
Like if the bidet is just like
not one if it.
- What's the other reason?
Do you have a warm ass?
- Yeah, one, I have a warm ass
and there's like two fucking
sacred places for me,
and one is the shower and the other one
is when I'm taking a shit.
Probably like my channel wouldn't exist
if I couldn't shit or shower.
'Cause where the fuck am
I gonna get my ideas from?
- You're having fucking
existential crisis on the toilet.
- Fuck, yes I am.
Who doesn't, do you not?
- No, because taking a
shit for me is enjoyable.
- Yeah, I have a great time.
- That's the reason...
People think that I take
such a long time to shit,
because I'm having like
a mental breakdown time.
No, I'm just having a fucking great time.
I'm just like, why would I leave early
when I'm having this much fun right here.
(laughs)
It's so fun.
- I fucking love shitting.
Bidets are just-
I don't know, in Thailand we
have like an even worse thing
which is like...
It's like a self bidet, right?
So in like most Southeast Asian countries,
we don't have like the
auto on your ass bidets.
We have like a little, like a shower head.
Like a mini shower head
that you have to put between your legs.
- Oh, some European countries
have that too, right?
- Yeah.
- With the little bowl?
The thing that...
Like the little bowl next to it
or you do it in the toilet itself?
- In the toilet.
- Its like the little
bowl thing but without the bowl.
- Oh, okay.
- And at that point,
I don't know, I've
always hated that feeling
'cause then you just get wet balls.
- That's too much,
(Joey laughs)
because the bidet is precise
with where it's aim is, right?
And when you've used your
own, bidet long enough,
you know where to aim.
- The bidet's like
sniping, you're asshole.
- Yeah you know where to aim your cheek
and you know the radius
of which it'll spread.
So you've got it down or not, right?
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- We talked about fucking-
- How long have we been talking about it?
- Showering our assholes.
- I've always wanted to
talk about it on the podcast
'cause it's one of the, no joke,
the most enjoyable parts of Japan.
- I know what to call this episode, now.
The Japanese toilet experience.
(laughing)
The shitting Japanese experience.
- I know where golden requiem
experience comes from now,
and it's when you're
on the fucking toilet.
(laughs)
- Were you a bit like
worried when you first saw
how to operate the bidet
when you first came to Japan?
- Yeah, I think a lot
of British people are,
'cause it's like, the
thought of spraying your ass
is so foreign to us.
- Yeah (indistinct)
- What was that thing
that you and Allen did again,
the first time you went to
the fucking hotel bidet?
- We were curious at how
the bidet knew when
you were sitting on it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The bathroom was like a wet room.
So we were like, okay,
well it doesn't matter
if this bidet sprays everywhere?
So we had like a few drinks.
We were like, let's figure
out how the bidet works.
So we figured out the bidet won't spray,
unless there's pressure on the seat
which is pretty fucking cool.
Yeah, and then it was
like spraying on the wall.
'Cause no one was sitting on it.
(Joey laughs)
- You were just like pushing it.
- Bro, this thing was going far.
It was spraying on the wall, it was crazy.
- That's the pressure that goes
up your asshole, man.
- And that's what I want
going on my ass.
- That's the pressure that goes up
your fucking asshole.
- I had a traumatic story
of 'cause...
In our house in Australia,
we always had a bidet
'cause my mom was like, "I
can't live without a bidet."
- Because she's Japanese
and she shits like a King.
Why would she go back to
shitting like a peasant.
- She's like, let me teach you.
Let me teach you Australians
how to shit like a King.
So we had it in our house.
But of course when I was
little, I didn't use the bidet
because I didn't know
what the fuck it was.
I was just like, oh, buttons,
but I didn't fucking press any of them.
(laughs)
- Yeah, I remember first
time seeing a bidet
and I'm just like, yo, do I need a license
to operate this shit?
(laughing)
- A bidet license?
So it was like, I feel like
if I pressed the wrong button
this toilet's gonna take off.
- Here is like the fucking
operating system of the bidet
that you can see on screen right now.
Especially like going
to Japan the first time,
and it's somewhat in the
different language as well.
- When I was little, like I
never knew how to use the bidet,
'cause I was just learned
to just make sure to wipe
and wash your hands and
then you'll be good.
But, when you get to
around age six or seven,
you start to get a little bit curious
what these buttons are.
You're just like, I wonder what this is.
So, I did the fatal mistake though.
So I pushed the bidet,
like start bidet button.
But I made the fatal mistake
of getting up off my seat
and looking down at the toilet bowl.
- Oh, no, it spray you in the face?
- So it fucking sprayed me in the eye
(laughing)
- Oh God.
- And there's just water going everywhere,
and I'm like, I don't
know how to stop this,
what the fuck's happening.
I actually thought I broke my toilet.
So, I called my mom and I was just like,
mom, come here.
So, she came in, fucking
bidet water going everywhere
in this toilet.
(laughing)
So it's just like, what the fuck?
And then the last thing she said,
like she finally stopped
it and she's like,
"You could have at least
flushed your shit, man.
"I didn't have to see that."
(Garnt laughs)
- But also, the bidet water is also warm.
- Yeah.
- So it's literally
like a warm shower.
- It is like a warm shower.
- Only, W's, only W's.
(Joey laughs)
- And you know thing is right is that,
if you're an American or your
just a Westerner in general
and you come and you see this toilet,
yeah, it can be daunting, right?
'Cause, normally things
don't go near your ass.
You're not used to that.
- No, no.
- Just embrace it.
It feels good.
It's scary.
- It's scary. (laughs)
- But once you admit
the thing feels good when
they spray your ass...
(laughs)
That could be so out of context.
- It's like discovering a new fetish.
- It's like, you now what-
- Just give it a go.
- Does it feel a little
erotic after... (laughs)
It feels fucking-
- It does.
But it feels good.
The wet ass afterwards
just doesn't feel good.
- Dry it, just dry, man.
- Just dry it man.
- It's not that hard.
- Then it doesn't feel clean.
I don't know, my asshole
doesn't feel properly clean
unless I soap that shit.
- There is no proper clean.
Like I don't feel properly
clean after a wipe.
I feel like 90% clean after a wipe.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause you know
there's always gonna be a little bit left.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- You know that bidet is
scraping that shit off.
Just pressure washing it.
- It's like washing your hands
without soap.
You might feel clean, but you don't really
until you use that soap.
- I know, I need to physically
feel my asshole being clean
and not like getting it washed.
I don't know.
I need to feel that shit, man.
I need to confirm with my own hands.
(laughs)
- Well then, that's what you should do.
You should use the bidet and
then wipe it with your hand
and see if it's still there.
- No, because it doesn't
feel properly clean to me
unless I fucking shower.
Like my asshole never
feels clean unless I shower
and I have probably soap in it.
- This man is like wasting
fucking buckets of water
to clean his ass, when he
can just be using a bidet.
(laughing)
- You can never take too many showers.
I love the feeling
of taking a shower.
- I'm pretty sure you can take
too many showers.
- Yeah, (laughs)
- I don't know.
- Your skin has natural oil
that if you shower too much
you get rid of it (indistinct).
- I don't know, for
me, I love the feeling.
especially in summer when it's hot.
Just taking like a nice-
- Yeah, that's different.
- A nice cold shower.
- That's a little different though.
That's a bit different.
- But even now in the winter
I take like three showers.
Like I get a bit cold-
- Three showers?
- You take three showers?
- Yeah, sometimes.
- Why?
- Not like-
- No wonder you don't
fucking upload videos,
you're always in the fucking shower.
- Not like properly long showers,
just like sometimes I get a bit cold-
(indistinct)
Like I said, my mind-
Like either I'm too
stuffy or I'm too cold.
So sometimes I can't be bothered to wait
for the fucking heater to go on.
Just pop in the shower, get
a bit of warm water on me.
All right, I'm back up to warm.
- This man spends more time in
the shower thinking of ideas.
Than actually committing
to the ideas. (laughs)
- This man is not the clown,
he is the whole circus.
You know what's also fucked
up as well about you Garnt?
- What? (chuckles)
- Hate to bully you this episode but,
you don't use your bath at all, do you?
- You and Sydney don't take baths.
- I don't either though.
- Sydney...
No, I mean, okay.
I don't like taking a bath in like...
it feels like I'm in like
a prison cell bath, you know what I mean?
I feel like I'm taking...
Okay, so Japanese baths are fucking tiny.
- They're not that...
Yours isn't that bad.
You can, sit in there.
- If I can't stretch legs out in the bath,
then it's not even a bath to me.
- I don't need to stretch them out fully?
- It's a glorified sink in that point.
- No.
(laughs)
(indistinct)
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The point is you have to
take a bath like this.
You do the fucking-
- It's not that bad.
- The L thing.
- You do the fucking
L position.
I'm like.
- No.
- Okay. (chuckles)
- So like-
- It's not that bad.
- I take like, I would say
90% baths, 10% showers.
- Really?
- No, no.
- Honestly, honestly.
Because in Japan, the
best thing is is that
you can like reserve your bath.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- As it says.
- Yeah.
- Which is like, if you know
what time you're waking up,
you can set the bath to be
full and hot by that time.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which, why the fuck
do we not have this in any-
- It's the biggest brain move.
- Would they have like NASA in the US
but they haven't figured out
how to fucking schedule a bath?
I know what time I'm gonna wake up.
I know what time I need
to be in that bathtub.
- Yeah.
- Why can I not do
this basic fucking function?
- Right, right right.
- Right?
And then also you have one button,
'cause in the UK, what you had to do
is just turn the tap on
and keep checking on it
every five minutes.
- Yeah.
- Pain in the ass.
In Japan there's one button that fills up
to the perfect amount of
the amount that you set
at the exact temperature that you set.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- This is the future man.
(Joey laughs)
Why wouldn't I take a bath every day?
- I just feel like for me baths
are not ergonomically designed for me.
'Cause I feel like I'm too
tall to properly appreciate
a good bath, right?
- You're not that much taller than Connor.
- You're not that much tall than me.
- Okay, 'cause I love onsens, right?
The reasons I love onsens
is I'm submerged in water
and I'm in a comfortable position.
I can never get in a comfortable position
in any of any of the baths
I've ever owned in my life.
'Cause here's the issue, right?
So I wanna stretch my legs out,
but then my body is above the water.
So you gotta submerge yourself
and then you unsubmerge,
and then your body just gets cold, right?
- Peak bath position is like
the water's up to like here.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Your arms out of the tub,
maybe watching something there.
That's the best.
- Yeah.
- Maybe got a beer as well
if you wanted.
- 'Cause then your upper body is cold.
I like-
- No way,
it's the perfect temperature control
because your head is free,
you've got this bit getting cold,
and then you got the rest
of your body boiling.
- Also because the bath water
is so hot, the steam from the hot water
makes the room warm, as well.
- I feel like you just haven't given baths
the true shot they deserve Garnt.
- Well, I-
(Joey laughs)
- Again, you're wasting
another potential of Japan,
which is how fucking good the bath are.
- No, the bath's are way too small here.
- No, no.
- I don't wanna be sitting.
- They're deep.
- If my legs are curled,
then that's not a bath to me.
- Well, you know we're doing-
- You're not fucking daddy
long legs in this (indistinct).
You're not that much taller.
- Next time I'm going to your house-
- Baths are meant to be relaxing
and I need to be in a comfortable position
to be relaxed.
- I don't fucking believe you.
- That's why I love onsens
and I just don't take baths.
Showers to me are just more relaxing.
- I don't believe you.
Next time I'm going to your house,
I'm forcing you to get in the bath
with your clothes on.
(Joey laughs)
You just sit there,
I wanna judge this
position, that's bullshit.
I don't believe you.
- We have one.
- Yeah, we have one in the
studio, go in this one.
- Okay, after this episode we'll-
- That ones tiny as well.
That one's too-
- Okay, that one
is actually smaller than normal,
but we'll get Garnt in there
and we'll vote what's going on.
We'll post the screenshot.
- The other thing of like I have...
- The only times I've had
baths is in my home in England,
and I don't know, the way, okay...
When you're in a bath, do you
put your legs towards the top
or do you put like your
back towards the tap?
- Legs toward the tap always
- Legs toward the tap,
of course.
- What animal puts their back
towards the tap?
- Because the tap is
always like, I don't know.
I always have like...
I don't know if it's just me but sometimes
I accidentally hit the tap,
and it's either too hot or too cold.
And it just like ruins
the entire vibe for me.
- You want the legs there
'cause you don't wanna burn your back.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- (chuckles) I've
actually done that before,
and I think that's just
completely-
- You're a clown.
You're a clown.
- Fucking mighty brain move
right here.
- Also, I saw your bath
at your parents' house.
It wasn't that nice.
Come on Garnt, come on.
You can do better than that.
- I mean.
(Joey laughs)
- Come on, come on, come on.
- Even if I'm in
a fucking nice hotel
I'm like, I don't take
a bath in this.
- Bro, there is nothing
better than a hotel that has
a big ass bath.
- Yeah I agree.
- That shit's amazing.
- That's the only time
where I'm exclusively like, fuck showers,
I'm going in that bath.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Always, always, always.
- Also, I like the feeling
of just having water
spraying on you.
I don't know, it's just like a nice
zen feeling.
- Well, then go out
into the rain. (laughs)
- Honestly rain in Southeast
Asia is fucking great, okay?
'Cause when we think of
rain we think of like cold
fucking depressing British
rain, just fucking...
It's like God blew up a
fucking raspberry on you
and I hate that feeling,
right?
(Joey laughs)
But in Thailand, when it
rains it fucking pours.
- Right, right.
- And it's probably like...
And it's warm as well.
It's like taking a warm shower
- Doesn't it feel like you're
just getting pissed on?
- Yeah, also it's so fucking humid
'cause it was doing that in Japan.
In the summer, it was raining.
And it was deceiving 'cause I'm like,
finally I'll be cold.
- Yeah.
- But no, it was just
more fucking heat directly
applied to my skin.
- That's what I hated about
when I went to the Philippines
for the first time and it was like May.
So it wasn't even like properly hot yet.
- Yeah.
- But because
this is Southeast Asia, it's
still fucking hot in may.
And the moment I got outside,
my hair just fucking turned
into an afro because of
the amount of humidity.
And then there was a pool
where we were staying.
So I was like, oh, thank God.
I can finally jump in the
pool and I'll call myself off.
No, because it was so humid outside,
it was like walking into
a fucking puddle of piss.
It was horrible.
I was like, I like heated
pools and I like regular pools,
but the temperature of this pool
is like halfway in between of that.
And it was just like lukewarm
kinda what I was just like.
- That makes makes you feel
like someone shit in it.
- Yeah, right.
(laughs)
It doesn't make the water feel clean.
- It's like perfect bacteria temperature.
- Yes. (laughs)
- Makes you feel real gross.
- Exactly, yeah.
- Bro that's why cold showers are like
fucking amazing.
- No, they're good.
- They're amazing.
- That's why when I used
to swim in public pools,
the best ones are like the
ones that are initially cold
but you get warm as you swim.
- Exactly, yeah.
- Because that's like nice.
'Cause then it also forces
you to keep swimming.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And you don't get to comfortable.
- That's the ones where you're just like
you feel the water and
you're like, oh, that's cold,
but I'm just gonna commit
and just fully jump in
and submerge my body all at once.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then
you're fine after that.
- Yeah, yeah, (indistinct).
- Yeah.
- Fuck, I can't believe
you're jus an animal Garnt.
(laughing)
You can take the peasant out of Thailand
but you can't take the peasant...
Sorry, Sorry.
The Thailand out of a peasant.
(laughing)
Fuck!
I messed that up.
- Nailed that.
- I have the superior taste.
(scoffs)
I'm just-
- Mr. don't eat crust.
- I just want to exist
happily, you know what I mean?
That's all I wanna do.
- I want you to exist correctly, Garnt.
I want you to use the bidet when you can,
and I want you to take a bath every night.
Treat yourself Garnt.
- Yeah, treat yourself.
- You deserve it, come on man.
- You're better than that.
- I don't want a wet fucking ass.
- You don't have to be, wipe.
That's what the toilet
paper was invented for.
- Then I don't want wet
fingers after a wipe.
That's just-
- How fucking weird is your ass.
- Are you clawing your ass
out with your bare hands?
What are you doing?
(laughs)
- Have you-
- Meilyne, your hands
don't get wet when you use a bidet,
do they?
- That's disgusting.
- Yeah, right.
- Right? See.
- It is disgusting, that's why I hate it.
- [Meilyne] You're not
using toilet paper, are you?
- No, I am using toilet paper.
- (laughs) Seriously,
he's just using his hand.
- He's using the-
- He's like, ah, fuck!
- He's using the heat of
friction to warm his back up
to evaporate the water off his cheeks.
What are you doing Garnt?
- He's ass cheeks are just like.
- Okay, you know what?
I wanna watch you shit after this.
I wanna see what you're doing.
I need to judge your technique.
You're doing it all wrong.
- Let's fucking do it, I'm ready.
Shit review, let's go.
- Can we get a GoPro
inside of the toilet bowl
and see what's going.
- Yeah, I want a bidet cam
just to see.
(laughs)
- I need to see what's going on.
I need to see what you're doing
in this fucking bowl, Garnt.
(laughs)
- Next special.
- The bidet special.
- The bidet special
Will Garnt be able to learn
how to use a bidet correctly?
- Needless to say, I am
100% bringing back a bidet
if I have a house-
- I am bring back a kotatsu.
I'm bringing back a heated
toilet seat and a kotatsu.
- Well, you don't need the table.
You can just get the heated
element and screw it on.
It's just a box that makes heat.
That's basically it.
- A box... (chuckles)
No, 'cause you need the heated element,
you need the table, and you need the cover
on top of the table
to place the blanket.
- Well, you can just
get another.
- Because the good thing
about a kotatsu is that
in the summer you can still use it
because all you have to do
is just take the sheet off
and then it turns back
into a regular table.
- Oh, okay. True, true.
- So it's like a
specially made table, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Kotatsu is a bomb.
- Kotatsus are like the
best thing in Japan.
- No (scoffs) best.
- One of the best things.
- Bidet.
- Heated toilet seats are-
- Bidet, all my homies
love bidets.
- Heated toilet seats
are a close second.
- I'm on team bidet in
this instance, I think.
I love my kotatsu but, man,
there's nothing more disgusting
than a gross asshole.
(laughs)
I'm just saying right there.
- How dirty is your...
I don't even wanna imagine.
- Maybe you guys are just shitting wrong.
- No, we're not sitting wrong Garnt.
You are-
- What's the wrong way
of shitting?
Like shitting on the wall?
- How is it wrong if I have a great time,
I end up perfectly clean, I'm very happy,
and my ass isn't wet?
I'm doing it the right way,
as far as I'm concerned.
- Yeah, you're sitting wrong if you end up
with a fucking swampy asshole.
- Garnt's like, instructions
unclear, I dropped as a child.
(Joey laughs)
What are you doing on this toilet, man?
Sort your fucking life out, bro.
- I'm thinking of fucking
bomb-ass videos on the toilet
and in the shower as well.
- Clearly you're not thinking
about personal hygiene
or staying dry.
(Joey laughs)
- I am very happy with
my personal hygiene.
- Men I have a poppy asshole
but I got a great video idea.
(laughing)
- That's exactly it, man.
That's exactly it.
(claps)
- Garnt's like literally stinky poo poo.
- Oh, oh stinky.
But Hey look at all these lovely Patreons
who are helping to support the show.
These Patreons of team bidet.
- A question to you
Patreons this time, right?
See what I did there, little reference,
'cause Garnt loves to say that.
That's the joke.
- Question to you.
- We boys we'd love to do a
tour or something in the US.
- Oh yeah, we gotta talk
about that, don't we?
- We have-
- Would you guys be interested
in us maybe doing "Trash
Taste" live across the US?
Would that be something that maybe-
- It's just a very brief idea, of course.
We can't do it now because of
the state of the world but-
- But maybe in like a year or something,
maybe doing it like that.
- Whenever the US gets its
shit back together, I think.
We'll definitely be open to that idea but,
are you guys open to that
idea is more of the question.
So, I guess let us know.
- Yeah, we wanna
gauge interest if that's something
you guys wanna do.
- So definitely let us know.
And if you'd like to support the show,
then of course go over to
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Check out our subreddit,
give us some memes,
and listen to us on Spotify
if you don't wanna see our faces.
But yeah.
- But why wouldn't you?
- Why wouldn't you.
- I want you to see in H, no, 4K, sorry,
me shouting at Garnt, about him being
a little uncultured
- About having a poopy
butt hole. (laughs)
- About being a little
stinky poopy poo poo.
- About our shitting technique.
(Joey laughs)
which I can't believe that we've...
I think half the podcast.
- You are literally fucking
gone Prenen when you shit,
and I'm like Netero
with all my eight hands,
slapping my ass clean dude.
You're so inferior, you
can't even fathom the level
that I am on, man.
(Joey laughs)
That's all I'm gonna say.
Thank you for watching this
episode of "Trash Taste."
- Yeah, hopefully you guys enjoyed it.
I Promise our conversations
will be a lot nicer.
- I hope you didn't eat this
with dinner, I really hope.
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
If you're eating this
with food, I'm sorry.
- We should probably have a warning
at the beginning now that-
- No, no, no.
- You know what you're getting into.
- You know what you're getting
into, it's Trash Taste.
We talk about anything.
- All right, see you guys
next week.
- Goodbye gamers.
- See you later.
- Bye.
- [Garnt] Bye.
(soft music)